[Laughter]
hey you guys happy friday
hooray
yep
yep
you thought the [ __ ] cat's [ __ ]
sticks were going to show up today
she's not chew sticks she's very upset
that
she loves well i mean other than
temptations which everybody knows are
like [ __ ] kitty crack right and this
video is not in any way sponsored by
temptations although probably ought to
be
but she does love those
the only other like little snack type
thing that she likes treats are those
shiba meat sticks
she likes most of the flavors but her
favorite is tuna weirdly though
tuna
seemed to be the hardest to get hold of
like i ordered some from amazon like a
big variety pack that had like chicken
salmon blah blah the tuna ones she is
all about that she will you'll hold the
meat stick out and she's like
and she eats the whole thing in like
three [ __ ] bites yeah she wants you
to hold it and you have to hold it you
can't put it on the floor
it doesn't work it's like a slim jim
yeah and she'll sit there and gnaw on it
and on it without taking a bite
for a long time yeah she licks it and
then sometimes she'll
bite half of it off and swallow it whole
yeah what the [ __ ] and she just just
starts and if you if you get sick of
that [ __ ] and put it down she gets mad
just ah and runs away yeah she gets she
shakes her head
and then she comes back and then runs
she runs out there
you're getting
yeah she wants you to hold it you're
ruining it for me it's [ __ ] hilarious
zach says i don't blame her i like meat
sticks too yeah okay zach
don't we all but yeah she mostly likes
the tuna ones and
for some reason like for a long time i
was ordering from amazon and they were
like oh the chicken and sambal ones are
super cheap but the tuna ones either
were out of stock or they were way more
expensive than the other flavors and i'm
like what the [ __ ] is going on with that
but then i found like kind of a cheap
one and i ordered like i don't know it
was like 15 or 20 of them but it's taken
like forever to get here i thought they
were going to be here today
and because she's been without them for
a couple of nights and she has a routine
where
you know when it's about seven or eight
o'clock and we've kind of like put our
jammies on and are like watching
something in the bedroom she knows to
come in and tom keeps them in the drawer
in the nightstand
on his side of the bed so she'll come in
and like sit there and look at him like
yeah she'll knock something off the
[ __ ] yeah and if you're not paying
attention she'll reach up there and go
yeah hey she'll grab something off the
lake knock something on this nightstand
and then look at you it's meat stick
time yeah and like i gave you some [ __ ]
she'll [ __ ] ask you four times
well and what she started to do the last
couple weeks she's got us weird is that
when it's it's a year in there and
she'll give you one but if you're not in
the room but i'm in the room
then she'll be like
and i'm like have you had one and she's
like i totally have not had yeah and i'm
like okay well i'm gonna give you one
then right but then like later when tom
comes back and she'll ask for another
one and i'm like
i just gave you one yeah she thinks that
everybody should give her two
every day so there's four
that we owe her for yeah it builds up
she builds up a resistance to yeah
because before she would just have like
one and that was enough enough now she's
built up where she got two out of me and
then she tries to get two out of her
yeah and she thinks that we don't
communicate with one another about who
is giving her the sticks yeah they'll
never know
so she thinks she's being slick
like trying to get me to give her one
because daddy's not here
i haven't had one today he's he's
starving me
please give me one
and i feel so bad because she just like
sits there and looks at you like
please yeah and you kind of have to
so my friend little small
he uh dropped me a message today and
he's like dude man
i saw the i saw the new batman it sucks
as it does because yeah man [ __ ]
batman's emo is [ __ ] it said he is
that's like christian but christian bale
said that
it says his people were clapping
afterwards man i don't know what they
were clapping at i didn't like that [ __ ]
so
i was kind of like down i was like oh
man it's gonna [ __ ] suck
so then i go well is it was it better
than the predator
and he goes and he goes no the predator
was better you know we're talking about
it was that predator four
yeah we're not talking about predators
yeah we're talking about that which is
what the [ __ ] man like call some [ __ ]
some other [ __ ] yeah really don't be
like naming things the same thing with
just an [ __ ] he goes no man the
predator was better this is kind of like
escape plan too
if you guys ever see a skate plant too
escape plan was [ __ ] good it had
arnold schwarzenegger and it had [ __ ]
um uh [ __ ]
sylvester stallone in it
and uh it was a good one it was fun
and then it comes out with part two and
part two was [ __ ] terrible horrible
and uh so he said no it's about like
escape plan too
and did i even see the first one
i don't know i liked it the first one
was really good i don't even remember
what that i don't remember so um
yeah sylvester stallone worked for a
company that
would he would get himself locked up and
he would escape from it and then rate
the prison he was like a security
company
and he ended up in this damn ultramax
prison
and had all these guys on there one of
them was like a terrorist played by uh
uh arnold schwarzenegger it was a good
movie
but uh anyway
so i was i was kind of like down i was
like man it must suck
but i was uh i went on uh midnight's
edge
on there and they're they're actually
talking good about it they said no it's
good they're real good see this is why i
don't especially
well no i mean i'm just saying if a new
movie comes out like i said unless
you're me are you me no then i don't
give a [ __ ] what your opinion about a
movie is i'm gonna go see if i want to
see it i'm gonna go see it yeah and if i
like it then i don't give a [ __ ] what
you think and if i don't like it i don't
give a [ __ ] what do you think because
like i said you're not me
opinions are subjective that's why in a
car
i mean i
i'll watch if i'm like doing a review of
it
i will watch other people's reviews of
it after i've seen it to kind of get um
a bead on like what other people are
saying about it or if it was well
received or not or what some people
people that didn't like it what their
criticism was what people liked about it
because i like to get like a wide range
of opinions on stuff but i never ever
ever ever watch reviews of stuff
before i see it because why the [ __ ]
would i do that like i said he said
batman was all emo
and i was like what the [ __ ] is he
talking about
so um
uh there's a guy on one of the guys
there is [ __ ] his name is uh
[ __ ] power pawn what was his name
he's an indian guy
and uh
he's in hollywood i just can't remember
his name but i always agree with his his
take on the movie he's been in a bunch
of he's worked on a lot of movies
and uh
he said that uh
it's a good it's it's a well-made movie
it's kind of like film noir
uh he said that
it's true to the character in terms of
like bruce wayne
he's got mental problems you know which
that was established in the other ones
but he he kind of has mental some mental
illnesses because of what what he went
through you know and and there's some uh
family history also there too where you
know the waynes weren't as good as like
we were led to believe in some of the
other movies
they're not re-rooted as totally like uh
legit in some ways
and uh this is kind of like his first
experience being the batman and uh he's
not really sure what batman has to be
you know so it's kind of like a batman
begins story
it sounds good to me
exactly well i mean the trailers looked
good that's all i've seen of it is the
trailer i'm not like i said i'm not
super into superhero that car though man
but yeah
but i was interested to see it because
it looked like
you know it looked like a cool take on
it like i said i'm not going to like
base my whole [ __ ] identity around it
or anything it looks like it might be
happening in the 70s it's it's hard to
say
which that would be neat yeah like that
uh cheryl asked what am i drinking oh we
ran out of orange juice so i'm actually
drinking vodka and apple juice i know it
probably looks like not all that
appetizing but i promise it's apple
juice um
tammy says our cats think they need
treats every time anyone goes into the
kitchen
yeah it's kind of like pookie at this
point not even treats but she's gotten
so used to me playing with her
with my hairbrush
um in the morning that every time i go
over to the dressing
you know sink to do anything at all put
makeup on you know brush my hair get a
cup of coffee whatever
she runs over there and is like brush
and then i'll pick up like a thing of
lipstick is this brush no
is that brush can i eat it no and then
she'll just like sit there and yell
until i [ __ ] do something grampher
says name a movie with crappy reviews
but you thought it was totally dope i'll
go first water world
you know what uh
i i actually haven't seen water world uh
it i don't think i've seen parts of it
it doesn't really look like something
i'd i'd really be into but
it's like mad max on the water
yeah that's what i heard it's all right
i know this is like really random and
it's like it's old it's like not even
one that
because i can't think of like a new one
that i was really into that everybody
hated
i can't really think of one but i can
think of one and take this with a grain
of salt because i haven't seen it a long
time
but
blair witch 2 book of shadows
i remember
everybody like [ __ ] on that movie
and actually everybody still shits on it
and said it's like the worst thing ever
um but i remember kind of liking it and
i actually remember i think i bought it
on dvd and saw it like multiple times
and i was like this is good i don't know
what everybody's talking about but i
haven't seen it a long time so i don't
know if it's i don't know if it's good
it was better than water world that had
kevin costner it was another post
post-apocalyptic apocalyptic flick it
was called uh the postman nobody liked
it i yeah i remember that yeah i liked
it i liked it i didn't see it either it
was it was pretty good it was based on a
set on a book
um
some people say that the movie was
actually better than the book um
it
it was okay it had a lot of [ __ ]
moral lessons in it
that weren't true but
it was okay it was all right
they had this uh
the united states kind of breaks apart
there's a pandemic hits it actually
sounds [ __ ] like [ __ ] that's going on
today
but it breaks apart into uh little
kind of like counties and tribal regions
and one of the dudes out there there's a
bunch of different factions fighting
over them one
over the us
one of them was called the army of the
eights
and they were just a kind of like a
an 1800s style
cavalry riding horses and they had many
guns and [ __ ] ar-15s and
you know black and red uniforms made out
of leather and [ __ ]
and they were just running around
making people farm they're kind of like
medieval nights in a certain way they
were trying to put something together
but they only lived by these uh eight
rules and the eight rules were pretty
true from what i remembered [ __ ] like
fear will destroy reason uh which that's
true you scare people enough they'll do
all kinds of stupid [ __ ]
justice can be dictated which you see
that uh
but it just had all these little things
and they were actually living by this
code
and they were branded and then
themselves
now i had read a synopsis they said in
the book they were actually better
because
they were all way above 100 years old
they had all these cybernetic implants
and they they had been kind of modified
because they're supposed to be in the
future they've been modified really to
live a long time
and they were kind of um
cyborgs you know
uh so it's kind of interesting but
anyway
kevin costner plays a dude he's kind of
like mad max kinda and he's just a bomb
walking around with the damn mule
and he finds a bag of mail and he tries
he thinks he can get paid with this
mailbag maybe he could get something to
eat so he decided he'd deliver it to the
town that it was addressed to and he
pretended to be the mailman and he
conned him into thinking that the united
states was back
and over time he started not cool kevin
he just caught him costner
thinking of his back but then he started
and then he told him that well i have to
stay here they told me to open up a post
office here
you know what i think i did see that
yeah it's that's coming back yeah see it
must not have made much of an impression
no but it's pretty well made it was
expensive and he goes there's a um
he said he decides i'm gonna make a po
washington dc told me to make a post
office here
and then people are like well what what
are you gonna what about the town next
to us there's gonna be a post office
over there because oh yeah we're gonna
put one there too so he starts
recruiting people and he actually makes
a post-op a postal service
well the army of the eights hear about
this and they're going united states is
back uh you know they get they're like
they don't believe it but they kind of
are afraid that maybe it is back
but uh
he ends up
uniting all these towns with this damn
post office system
and they end up fighting the army of the
eights
and uh but it's pretty good it's a
pretty good little story
i just i think i can go to the show i
think i did see it dude who started off
as a con man basically
he accidentally stumbled into being like
an okay dude he stumbled into being like
almost like
a new founding father of a new [ __ ]
country you know what i mean
it was started to work
yeah so he
so he just went with it yeah zach says i
saw parts of the postman all i could
think of was how much harder can costner
jerk his ego off yeah
pretty much uh pretty much that's kind
of what i'm not even sure you could get
that on blu-ray maybe you can
i imagine you can't it's like every
movie nowadays has an audience it's long
it was a long movie from when i remember
so that's a little self-indulgent i got
it yeah
well the whole movie was evidently uh
like some dude
some direct some producers [ __ ] it
was his uh vanity piece you know i mean
he spent a [ __ ] ton of money on it and
it bombed at the theater
yeah that's the thing you know i'm all
for like following your dream and it's
like if you want to make a movie and
it's like i want to make a movie and
it's three hours long it's about this
that the other you do you but don't like
expect everybody else to want to see it
as well i mean if they do awesome but
zack says i really love the first silent
hill movie the sequel is totally ass
though i remember yeah i remember liking
the first one um i don't think i saw the
second i didn't like the first one
enough to like see any more of them but
and i don't really and i never played
the game so i don't really know
uh let's see what hold on
i saw something else
um
i was going to
uh
because somebody said the book of the
postman was better
and then for some reason that made me
think of
movies that were because you said you
thought like some people said the movie
was better than the book so i was kind
of thinking of other situations where
that was true that is almost never true
like in 99 of the cases the book is
always better i mean oracle's saying
that the book was better yeah but you
know that i guess that's open to
interpretation some people said that the
[ __ ] movie was actually better than i
mean it depends on what you know
the only
thing
i mean i'm sure there's more than one
but the only thing that i can think of
right now where i liked the movie better
than the book because that almost never
happens
was
the hunger
yeah uh you know in 1983 david bowie
catherine if you know the vampire movie
uh the book was by whitley strieber
and i did read it
um i liked it but and i i did like that
it went more into like miriam's
backstory like her whole like ancient
egypt kind of uh situation
but
the book i don't know i just i didn't
like the book as much as the movie i
don't know why
whitley strieber and maybe it was
because by that point by the time i read
the book i already knew that whitley
strieber was the dude that said that
he'd been pro by aliens like for real
and i was kind of like does this man
have any credibility should i even
be reading this but i wanted to read it
because i love the movie so much and
usually the book is better but in that
case the book was okay i just liked the
movie better
uh is that a window on the right can we
see outside yeah that is a window uh you
want you won't see you won't see
anything except like a big long driveway
it's just because all that's out there
because the my office is right over the
garage
so all you see is uh the driveway and my
old shitty ass car sitting in the
driveway i could take a video of it yeah
tom could take a video of it but we
can't well you yeah you could do it and
then like
hold it up right now then i have to open
that damn shade though i'll just take it
through the uh through the other window
there you go ooh my creepy ass phones
i'm gonna have to change that ringtone i
have i i downloaded an app that's all
like um
it was all like horror movie
uh
music
for ringtones just generic like horror
movie ringtones and i just i don't know
i liked that one well that was the first
one that i liked out of the 50 bajillion
that's in there so i don't know i didn't
really have time to like go through and
[ __ ] change everything
um
yeah i mean i don't know we might go see
we might go see the batman this weekend
because honestly we're still paying for
that [ __ ]
uh amc stubs thing and we haven't been
to the we haven't been to the movies
since nightmare alley came out all right
okay so this is like the room that's
right next door which is just like the
gym it doesn't have any curtains or
anything because there's my shitty ass
car look at my little shitty car
that's outside
damn it
everything that makes me backwards
well yeah
yeah that's just that's the room that's
like right there yeah room right there
it just has all that's in there it's you
know it doesn't we haven't painted it
there's no curtains there's no nothing
all that's in there is like tom's weight
thing
it's gonna be the gym although it used
to have my exercise bike in it but then
i was like why am i putting my exercise
bike in there because i usually use the
exercise bike in here so i can watch
some [ __ ] on my computer so i just leave
it in here now so it's over there
um let's see
the road is fantastic yeah
we're talking about oh they're talking
about the movie the road
um yeah i actually really liked that
movie the book is good too i actually
read the book too i mean it's a big
bummer but
you know
um somebody was saying something about
nightmare alley honestly they thought it
was
i was kind of bored i felt like kept
starting and stopping
um honestly i don't know why yeah like
that's yeah that's a legit opinion i
loved nightmare alley though i don't
know why there was just something it had
like all the [ __ ] that i like
you know what i mean it had like noir
[ __ ] it had like carnival [ __ ] it's like
i was i was all i was all about it
and
interestingly
and this review will not be going up
until
next week wednesday or thursday
um i finally got around to seeing
guillermo del toro's last movie shape of
water which i don't know why it took me
so long to see it but i finally did so i
did a review of that earlier because i'm
doing for march uh on my flickers of
fear show i'm doing uh monster movies so
i'm trying to figure out i don't know
it's it sucks because i
had wanted to do
some universal monster movies because
shutter had a whole bunch of them and
had like a whole bunch of like boris
karloff stuff had frankenstein brian
frankenstein the mommy had all that kind
of stuff so i was gonna do all that and
then i went on there today because i was
gonna watch bride of frankenstein and
it's gone
so i guess they only had
like a limited time
and i was like well [ __ ] i mean i can
still watch it it's just now i have to
pay for it like you know three or four
bucks or however much it is instead of
watching it for free on shutter shutter
just added but they took off most of
their universal stuff
but um they just added a bunch of like
new french extremity
um
so
you know they added some stuff like
irreversible which i already reviewed
and uh trouble every day which i've been
wanting to see for a long time so i
might get around to that as well that's
been on my list forever but there's a
bunch of that on there i'm talking to
keith he's in there but he's talking to
his friend about
hrt you know man you can't
that's right
what
are you gonna share it with the whole
[Laughter]
hugo says my ringtone is tails from the
crypt
yeah cheryl says shutter does that stuff
disappears fast other things are always
there yeah i noticed because
some things like for my book reviews and
for like basically everything that i do
like that i record like by myself
i do
a month in advance so i make a little
calendar and i'm like i'm going to read
these books this month and i'm going to
do these movies
and then sometimes by the time i get to
the point where i'm going to watch them
they're gone from like the because i
usually try to pick from services i
already have because i don't have to pay
extra
you know for [ __ ] i mean i will if it's
something that i really want to save but
it's yeah it's annoying so like i said i
did shape of water because that was on
hulu and it's still there and uh then i
was gonna do bride of frankenstein and
then i went on shutter today and i'm
like where the [ __ ] is bride of
frankenstein like all of the universal
movies are gone now they had like a [ __ ]
ton of them on there
and then they only had them for like a
month and they're gone but like i said
it has to do with like rights i suppose
and
you know
so i i'll probably still do bride of
frankenstein it's just that now i have
to like pay 3.99 to see it which i
that's fine that's fine but i don't know
yeah monster movies cool i yeah i'm
trying to like i don't know it's kind of
hard for me to like pick which ones i
want to do because i'm not super into
um
kind of traditional monster movies in
the sense of like godzilla or stuff like
that
um because i thought about doing like
godzilla but i was like well i don't
know do i really i've seen a lot of
godzilla movies and gamer movies because
of uh mystery science theater but
it's not really my favorite
thing
i would rather see
i don't know there's a lot of ones that
i have on my list so i'll see which ones
i get around to but what's more i
definitely did want to do some universal
ones though
but this actually if you have if you're
on our patreon you should have already
seen because i did uh the beast must die
with peter cushing
which is a werewolf movie it's a
werewolf
who done it it's like an agatha christie
it's like an agatha christie thing but
with a werewolf instead of a murderer
but i guess i mean a werewolf is also a
murderer you top that up with some more
eyes
uh sure yeah
uh cheryl says i wonder if feast is on
the list uh it could be uh it could be
so uh you know i'm just
actually i might write it down because
like i said i'm looking for
for stuff to do i have some stuff on
there that i want to do but i'm not
really sure like what ones i'm gonna do
yet you know what i'm saying because
some of the stuff that i was gonna do
it's like not there anymore and i'm like
well maybe i should like rethink the
[ __ ] i don't know so
i try to keep it flexible even though i
try to like plan ahead but you know how
it goes you know how it goes i'm just
i'm using this like piece of mail
because i'm too lazy to like go over
there and get other paper
can i write on that okay feast let's
write that down
i was thinking about doing at least one
like bigfoot type movie
because there's one called exists
and there's one called monstrous
that is on shutter but i've heard that
one wasn't that good
so
if anybody has any
um suggestions for monster movies
that they want me to do
old ones or new ones it doesn't matter
then let me know and i'll try to
accommodate you because i haven't like
finalized anything
um you know
it's i was looking at this one list i
think it was paced magazine and they had
done like 50 best monster movies and
they were trying to like make a
distinction between
what constituted a monster you know what
i'm saying because they're like okay
well it can't be human
um and they didn't really want it to be
like a vampire or something or a zombie
or something like that because that's
kind of its own thing
but it didn't necessarily have to be
like a big
you know like the host or uh you know
cloverfield or godzilla movies or
something like that
and it could be
a natural animal like jaws or something
but it had to be like extraordinary in
some way they had like all of these
rules
cheryl says ooh bigfoot yeah they're so
surprisingly i'm not i'm not and i'm not
doing um
i'm not doing uh what's that [ __ ]
arkansas bigfoot movie
boggy creek yeah
i'm not doing boggy creek
but there have been like uh i might do
exists because i've heard that one was
good
that's a that's a bigfoot type sasquatch
type movie but because i saw that that's
on uh that's actually on youtube for
free i think and on tv for free
i like i said i'm looking for stuff
that's for free i will pay for [ __ ] if i
have to
um you know if it's something i really
want to see but i would rather
you know see something that's uh on a
service that i already pay for like
amazon prime or hulu or shutter or
something like that because i'm already
paying for the [ __ ] so or netflix
because we pay for netflix too so you
know if it's on there but like i said if
it's not like don't worry about it i
still might do it anyway uh yeah that
korean movie host is good i was maybe
thinking about doing that one because
i've seen that like multiple times but i
don't think i've ever reviewed it
so
uh that invaders from mars karen black
80s flick that tom always talks about is
a good monster movie i actually put that
i think i put that in the poll i
remember it for the retrospective this
week so if you want to go if you're on
patreon go and vote for it because i'm
pretty sure that that is
i put it in the poll because it's on 2b
for free like you can watch it for
nothing
so uh reign of fire is my favorite
dragon movie that's actually on amazon
prime or something i just i remember
just seeing that yesterday
abominable 2001 great bigfoot film with
jeffrey combs in it
oh okay i might have to look i might
have to look that up i knew there had to
be something like that i was gonna do
troll hunter
but then i saw again
that it was on
shutter and now it's gone which sucks
so i yeah they'll have [ __ ] it won't be
up there for very long well like i said
it all has to do with like rights yeah
you really do have to like watch stuff
immediately like because it won't unless
it's a shutter original or like one of
their indie movies if it's like an old
one you better get in there and like
watch that [ __ ] because you don't know
how long it's gonna be up here about a
week yeah well it's like you it's
usually a month i think it goes month to
month although they do add new [ __ ]
that's the cool thing about shutter they
do add new [ __ ] every single week
and if they add one thing like i said
you know last one they put up last month
um that really awesome documentary about
boris karloff and they added a [ __ ] ton
of universal movies they had the mummy
they had frankenstein the bride of
frankenstein the black cat which we
talked about they had all that stuff uh
white zombie is still on there i think
although is that universal i don't
remember
bella lugosi's in that but um that's
actually really good maybe i'll do that
too but that's not a monster movie
whatever but so
that's a lot of yard do i take care of
it as of right now there hasn't been any
need to do anything because it's it's
kind of winter to just been
watering it and uh
planting some stuff out in the back
that's all we've been doing but uh no we
we had a uh a lawn crew
that used to come here and cut it
uh before we bought it and then they
disappeared i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened to him i could always get
another one
but usually you know
what you do is you just use whoever the
neighbors you use it
yeah and uh they'll come in for like a
you know 100 bucks a month or 80 bucks a
month depends on what the deal is
and they'll cut everything and trim all
the damn bushes yeah cause this is a big
ass yard and in the summertime you have
to have somebody come and cut the grass
and cut your hedges and stuff
every week or it will look like a big
[ __ ] swampy snake it looks like ass
so
uh oracle says you see that's just the
front the back is damn near
like a half a acre it's big
there's a lot more of it out in the back
yeah oracle says uh colossal is on yeah
that is actually one that i was planning
on doing
so that one is already on the list
because i saw that it was on
uh
it was on hulu so yeah i'm gonna do that
one
as well and then i'm gonna write down
the host because i had been thinking
about doing that one anyway
but you know
i just wanted some more ideas because i
have some written down on my little
calendar right there but
i don't know i don't know it's always
kind of like i try to plan ahead but
then sometimes i'm kind of like man i'm
not really in the mood for this one
right now i want to do a different one
uh
yeah cheryl says i haven't seen it never
wanted streaming here i just heard it
was good uh danny rowling says willow
creek sucked yeah i've kind of heard
mixed uh stuff about that like some
people liked it and some people didn't
uh yeah bobcat gold weight directed it
so
i had been wanting to see it but
i just hadn't got around to it yet like
i said my my list is [ __ ] long
and then i'll show you guys the back
oh you got a video in the backyard i'll
just go out there and take it oh okay
because honestly sometimes i watch so
many movies
for this like to review the show so
sometimes in the evening like you know
in the evenings like we'll watch movies
like from matinee or for movie
retrospective or whatever but then
sometimes when we don't have a movie to
watch like for the matinee show i kind
of want to watch something else or
something that i don't really have to
pay that much attention to
so
sometimes like for instance like last
night we didn't really have anything we
had to watch
so i actually ended up watching the
finale of next level chef the gordon
ramsay show because i wanted to see who
won i'm not going to spoil it in case
you haven't watched it yet because it
only i guess the finale what because
what i would usually do because we do
the show on wednesday night and i think
it airs on fox on wednesday night um
i watch it on hulu on thursday nights
so
if anybody's been watching next level
chef it's actually really good but they
did the um
they did the finale but i won't tell you
who won i'm i'm happy that who won
although any of the three finalists i
would have been happy if they won they
all seemed pretty cool uh so there was
that and then i discovered this show
completely at random on [ __ ] to be
when i was looking for something else
and it's called
bizarre murders
and the episodes are short they're only
like 23 minutes long i don't know where
it originally came from oh here we go i
see it okay
that's backyard
that's the planters
yeah i mean that's the neighbors yeah
that's the name is over there that's the
whole thing
goes almost all the way down to that
hedge down there
see those edges it goes all the way to
there it's all sprinklered too it's a
sprinkler system out there
and that's the neighbor's yard next on
the other side of that fence
and here's the refrigerator with the ice
machine
and all the best there's the eyes and
all the booze
that's where i'm going i got my new
french fries then i open it i'm gonna go
yeah there it is loaded look at all the
all those snacks oh and that's iced
coffee there yeah look look our c
our c [ __ ] this is the south you got
southern coming in my rc yeah oh
that's what that's what the main hallway
looks like up on the second floor
and then look
that's my new couch
i just bought it and there's jenny
she's doing the show that was a few
minutes ago
[Laughter]
yeah danny rowling says oh yeah i've
been wanting to watch that uh the the
movie deep house that's like an
underwater haunted house movie yeah i
just saw that come up um
the other day it's on amazon prime or
whatever it's on and i was like oh yeah
i remember that you said something about
that and i was like underwater haunted
house i'm i'm [ __ ]
uh you know on it but i haven't got
around to
watching it yet but you know
uh
david june says but rc soda is based out
of evansville indiana it's yankee soda
no
georgia
it originally came from georgia and then
it got right now it's [ __ ] owned by
schweppes so that make it british
oh yeah that's right schweppes yeah
british they make some nice uh ginger
ale actually
jason willie says would you guys review
the crocodile dundee movies
we could yeah i remember liking those
did i see the second one probably i kind
of feel like that was on uh cable a lot
back in the old days
oh the room y'all in is way bigger than
i thought that's what yeah that's what i
was saying when i first came in here
i kind of think because the quote
unquote master bedroom in this house is
actually downstairs
but i think that this room which is
upstairs was the one that was intended
to be like the other master bedroom
because it's big and there's like a
bathroom like attached
but
like i said we didn't make this the
master bedroom because it has it doesn't
have high ceilings
but
so there was that but yeah so this room
is like
probably
i feel like i
it's like twice the size of my old
office and the old house i don't know if
it's twice the size but it's for sure
way bigger
i mean the fact that i can fit
essentially three or four desks in here
and a couch
and
like three or four bookshelves
i mean that's kind of
i i think i when i was in tampa my
apartment was about this size
except it had a kitchen
but honestly if i'm trying to think
when i lived in tampa i had a studio
apartment
it was 500 square feet
and
it was probably about
maybe slightly bigger than this but not
that much bigger
and when i lived in clearwater i lived
in a um
lives in a studio apartment too yeah
there are ponds here there's a there's a
pond a small lake
just up the street here and it has a
landing you can get in there
and uh you can put a boat in it so they
allow you to put your they got people
they put canoes in there
and
fishing you can fish in it yeah but some
of the some of the other two-story
houses like this one are backed up to it
and they have their own little boat
landings
so if you if you bought like [ __ ] some
of the better real estate even though
the house might be the same but the land
that it's worth a little bit more if
it's backed up against that pond
and uh it's got a more complicated
driveway system and they got a boat
there
there's about five or six of them like
that
yeah they do have if you walk around the
neighborhood they do have like a little
it sort of looks like a little park
because there's like a little bitty
tennis court um but has a fence and like
a little bitty like playground yeah and
then across the street from that there's
like a little
it's like a little park here there's
like a couple benches
and
if you live in the neighborhood you can
go down there and fish or like launch
your boat off tila just shows up tilly
you missed i have a show in the house
man
i got it recorded i guess i could show
it again later
amy wants to know jenny where can i get
a 13 o'clock jacket in a 4x
um jackets we don't have a jacket well i
do have i do make these like these uh
little
oh that's right that's like little
jacket like that yeah i'd have to go on
zazzle and see what's on there because
i've had some on zazzle but i don't
really remember like what all designs
are on there um but i'll go and check
for you actually no we can i can i can
screen one
yeah we could actually screen
be easier to screen print one it
probably because i already have all the
graphics for it
trail so uh what you do is you get her
contact and get back with her
and we'll see how what jacket she wants
and we'll have her choose that and then
we'll give her a price
i don't know what jacket she's talking
about if she's just talking about a
sweater a hoodie that'd be the [ __ ]
cheapest
yeah cause this here is i just i made
this one on zazzle
this is i just have this in here because
it's [ __ ] cold in here during the day
this is my uh who put bella in the witch
elm one
and i just made this on
uh
if i could figure out like how the back
of it worked that would be awesome but
you know i'm kind of [ __ ] like that
but yeah it looks like that and then the
front of it just on the lapel
or the little where is it
it has the logo on it somewhere yeah and
it just has the logo on the front like
that like i said i've had this for
i don't remember how long
but i just got that on zazzle i made it
but it is uh hoodie's fine she says okay
well yeah
we'll get with me about that and we'll
get her to figure something out yeah um
because we can like i said we can make
you a custom one because we can spring
screen print [ __ ] yeah we got a supplier
that'll send shirts and all kinds of
stuff so
they probably also have
hoodies don't they they have everything
they have everything okay they have
every conceivable which like i said is
sometimes it's hard because i go in
there to order shirts and i'm like i
just want a black t-shirt and they're
like which of these 15 different kinds
of black t-shirt do you want we have
like a soft one or like a fitted one or
we have once we get that done once we
get that done we'll know that as we have
an estimate of the prices we can give
them a price
and maybe we'll make a we'll give them
an option if people want hoodies we'll
make some
we got to get the canon shirt done
and and the oats and the omni consumer
product robocop shirt gotta get that
done there's another one i was wanting
to do
what was that other one remember god
damn it you and that
[Laughter]
do you remember what that other shirt
was that was going oh that'd be a badass
shirt uh
no do you understand do you know how
many different things i have to like
remember in my head all the time what
she does
well i i try to write things down
because otherwise i can't remember
everything but if i don't remember to
write it down then a couple days later i
absolutely will not remember all right
so i definitely have to get those other
two i mean i'm pretty good at
remembering stuff but
even i can't hold everything in my brain
like at one time
uh cheryl said the screen's available
yeah we got we yeah we can do that and
i've got i got solution already made up
i got to make it before it goes bad
yeah that's right because that doesn't
last forever doesn't last forever uh
cheryl says when does the sexual
policeman shirt come out
you're gonna have to like put on some
wigs and uh
policeman doesn't wear a shirt she's
trying to kick myself
she's trying to get me if i can take my
shirt off
can i if i made you a shirt that said
sexual policemen on it would you wear it
you don't have to wear it outside i'm
not that [ __ ] to the club
you probably would have to wear it to
the club it would have to be kind of
like it would have to be kyle like
[ __ ] sid vicious [ __ ] shirt with
the two gay cowboys on it it had to have
[ __ ] it had to to have leather cops
on it okay yeah i could do that you
could dig up some leather cop [ __ ] uh
sure [ __ ] art
yeah yeah
i get all kind of fun should i yeah
tammy says yes we want hoodies jason
willie says would love a plisken cap
okay yeah that's a good idea yeah we
could do that uh i think i got an image
small enough for that for a hat i don't
have an image small enough i'd have to
make a new one well i can yeah i can
make anyone go thank you very much tila
oh would you rather go up against the
penguin or the joker and why and tom
take your shirt off i'll take that [ __ ]
off
i gotta get fired up first
he's still too sober
murder hornet says t wants time to pole
dance that's what i that's what we need
in here a pole
yeah you know
oh well i guess he doesn't
i guess he doesn't have to be drunk
it's your bald ass head
my sexual shirt sexual hat on
you're saying that's not the sexual hand
you need yourself
you need your [ __ ] sucker hat that's
right you need your [ __ ] sucker ready to
blow
granthar says okay i'm out of here for
10 minutes
david june gives ten dollars and says
tom keep your shirt on
ew don't do that
what don't do that what
don't do that hip-hop
just
and that's without a pump that's just
[Laughter]
you just settle down it's so early still
it's not even 6 p.m
what is this shenanigans pull up your
drawers there plumbers says granthars
[Laughter]
uh jason willie says jenny next to strip
yeah that's not gonna happen
that's not gonna happen
[Laughter]
now they're trying to get me to see what
you did see what you did
who spiked tom's drink nobody
he's just well at least he's in a good
mood today
[Laughter]
laughing
well you know what exactly in the past
it's still on there it's it's it's a few
minutes behind oh is that yeah yeah okay
you're lagging yeah
uh
yeah let's see
hey this is a family show is it okay
i thought it was let's see that and now
you [ __ ] missed it this is the addams
family yeah that's what this is
holy [ __ ]
yeah you might have to like back it up
be careful yeah it's all right i don't
care
i don't care
without your hair tom's head looks like
a thumb that's a sexy
[Laughter]
can i can i call you thumbprint from now
on
david paid me ten dollars to keep my
shirt on
yeah see you need to yeah keep that up
yeah
now now he'd be like he sent us 50 or
he's gonna take his pants off
jason said you look like uncle faster oh
they're seeing the pleasure trail there
is no pleasure trail i'm totally shaved
i always heard it called the happy trail
yeah i don't know that's like the happy
trailer yeah
i don't know that's the first time i
heard that was like in high school
like my friend said that i'm like okay
but yeah i guess that's what it's called
tom thumb yeah
that's historical
oh my god so many shorts we could make
all at tom's expense
i'd give a [ __ ] about you [ __ ]
i know you don't it's fine
it's fine i'm just letting alcohol
[ __ ] seep in
let it flow through you yeah
just like the [ __ ] the force or
whatever
one good [ __ ] yeah i get it
now la i remember i don't know why but i
remember somebody asked us about because
we actually went to mannequins
last friday after the show and somebody
asked us how that went and i don't think
we ever answered it
but
it was fun
yeah it wasn't very many people i mean
people there were there weren't people
we knew yeah like our main friends i
mean some some people we knew turned out
but like most of the people and honestly
we were [ __ ] tired when we showed up
i was tired when i showed up i had one
drink and i could barely finish it and
then like the rest of the night i just
drank water yeah so i just told anna and
she started waking up she started waking
up and wanted to do [ __ ] well and then
like after i went through all the water
after i went through all the water i was
like oh i feel better now because i kind
of felt like crap when we were going i
was like oh i'm so tired and i was like
i already drank a lot and blah blah but
then he was like no we gotta go we gotta
go and i'm just like okay and then like
i was like oh [ __ ] man i feel so shitty
and then i just started like drinking
and i just drank like gallons and
gallons of water and then like after an
hour or two i'm like now i feel awesome
and he was like no let's go
so you know it didn't work out too good
um honestly oh you know what oh [ __ ] i
forgot i was going to actually show
the
photo that they took at the last memento
mori
and i had it
like i got it and i sized it and
everything like that and i was gonna
download it and put it in obs and i
totally forgot
um tom didn't get in it because he was
at the bar like at the front bar but i
was in it i was like right in the front
actually but it was like a good picture
it kind of showed like not everybody
because some people had already left
because it was closing
but kind of got like a lot of the
regulars in the picture that was kind of
cool
but
i guess i can't i guess i can't do it
now because
unless you bring it up on facebook
what's that that picture the last
memento mori picture
i don't have it well you could go to my
facebook
yeah site and then it's on because i'm
tagged in it
you're not in it but i was meant to show
it and it's just like i forgot to
download it
tom male gigolo yeah maybe you could
make some money like that
i gotta find it on your on your [ __ ] let
me see
it should only be a couple down because
like i said i was tagged in it there's
like a couple like movie reviews but
that's but that's it
should be there like i said i'm tagged i
think angel tagged me in it yeah i found
it yeah i just wanted to show that
picture that was like the last moment of
morning demetrius like right there in
the front
yeah oh look there's jenny where am i
where's my finger other way there you go
right there there's me yeah
so you touched it i touched it sorry
[Laughter]
i didn't mean to touch it don't touch it
okay i'm just trying to touch it and
then there's that's dimitri right there
and then that's adam
there's angel like two back
yeah there's like a whole [ __ ] bunch
of people yeah but that was like they
took that like right
at closing time they turned the lights
on
and took a picture oh [ __ ] we [ __ ] the
lighting up again
go back to dark i don't like all of this
light it's like making me oh it's not
working
look at it look at it it went all
it's like all
why does it do that
okay there it goes
it's dimitri the dj yeah
and uh actually yeah he's um him and his
wife jen jen is in that picture too
our
you know some of our dearest friends
uh tila said jenny i saw a film called
fresh on hulu
yeah i've heard a lot about that uh and
so yeah that's definitely on my list to
watch because that sounds really good
it's about cannibals
um speaking of which oh that's what i
was saying before
i found this show randomly on toby
called bizarre murders
and i don't know what uh
channel it originated on it's i'm
assuming it originated on a channel with
commercials it's only like 23 minutes
long
and what it does is they take like
really weird murders that
really happen but then they kind of like
change it a little bit like they change
people's names and like they change a
few of the details and stuff i guess so
they can
because
the tone of the show
is a little bit
kind of jokey so you could kind of say
it's like in bad taste because people
did actually get murdered
um
but
most of the [ __ ] like the criminals that
are on there are such dumb asses because
there's this one guy who's he's not
really the host but he's kind of like
the guy that they go she was like an fbi
investigator and he's always like making
these snarky ass comments about like how
stupid like the murderers were and stuff
because they got caught
but
for some reason like i find the show
even though it's talking about real
murders like kind of hilarious and it
talks about stuff that
like it did a show about uh who was that
german [ __ ] that the cannibal armin
muse yeah i don't know yeah yeah yeah
the the guy armin muse that was his name
we did a show about him uh the guy that
you know uh met the guy online
and ate him which you know the guy
wanted to be eaten so you know fair
enough whatever uh so they did a show
about that but they changed everybody's
names they did a show about
that i think we also talked about that
woman that had um
munchausen by proxy and told her
daughter her entire life that she had
all of these medical problems and like
made her be in a wheelchair and yeah
told her she was like six years younger
than she actually was and blah blah blah
and then like the girl eventually like
snapped and like killed the mom yeah um
i think we talked about that on show too
so they did one like that but they
changed the names but it was enough to
like know
you know what it was still
so i don't know i've just been watching
there's a [ __ ] ton of them like on tubie
and i just i found it randomly and i'm
just like oh my god this is like so
[ __ ] up and yet so hilarious so
so i started watching it my favorite one
so far and i don't know what case this
was actually based on because i hadn't
heard about it
but it was this one where
this dude was married to this woman
they'd been married a long time and i
guess
she wanted to divorce him
um he kind of he worked at like a he was
a manager of
like an adult superstar type situation
but then he was making okay money doing
that but then he got
fired
and
so he was kind of a bomb and blah blah
and it was his wife was a nurse and she
made a lot of money and so she was gonna
divorce him
uh because he was starting to like lose
it
and
so he decided that he was gonna pay
this dude that worked with him at the at
the porno store to kill her
so he gave the dude the key to their
house
and they decided oh we should kill her
with a hammer
for some reason even though it's like
super messy come on just [ __ ]
evidence everywhere but look at amateurs
but yeah so it was that the awesome
thing about this was that the guy breaks
in the house
hides in the house the woman comes home
from work like i said she's a nurse
he comes and he hits her in the head
with a hammer and she kind of like falls
over on the floor but then she like
wakes back up and she kills the dude
with her bare hands like they struggled
for like half an hour and she ended up
like [ __ ]
just like [ __ ] strangling him like
that like he died
she killed him
uh and i was just kind of like holy [ __ ]
and it's like so funny because like then
the cops
are like trying to like figure out why
was this dude in the house and this dude
like had texts from the husband and
stuff it was just [ __ ]
that one was funny because the person
that ended up
uh you know the person that was
supposedly like supposed to be killed
like the the wife
she actually like fought back and killed
the guy so you didn't feel too bad about
like that guy get a killed because he
was like a [ __ ] run but yeah don't
mess with nurses man yeah that's kind of
like uh what they said because they said
well she was a nurse and she had had
like a lot of self-defense training
because you know she had to
uh subdue patients and whatnot so when
he tried to like hit her in the head
with hammer she was just like oh no
we're not happy that
she just like [ __ ] she just like
fought the [ __ ] he she just like fought
him down on the [ __ ] floor for like
half an hour and then she ended up
[ __ ] killing him and it was like
[ __ ] hilarious but we've been on
already uh an hour okay so we're how
we're into the show show has officially
started
uh we got we've got a pretty good crowd
in there
today is the day
where it's friday it's kind of it's open
lines friday every [ __ ] show doesn't
open live friday because they're easy to
do and they're fun
if you have any questions on any of the
[ __ ] cases that we've done in the
back we've done it
done in the back catalog or in the past
we can talk about that
uh if you have any questions about
paranormal [ __ ] unsolved mysteries
murders
um
[ __ ] current events just anything
anything that's on your mind just drop a
drop a question in the uh comment
section and jenny and i will get on it
we'll also talk about movies and take
any kind of requests or suggestions now
we did just unders we did just um take a
request for getting hoodies together
somebody was interested in a hat
yeah well we'll look into that too we'll
see if that supplier has though yeah i'm
gonna have to like right well yeah they
do they have pretty much any articles
you can think of we use jiffy shirts by
the way yeah um
who i've always really liked right my
favorite brand to hat is condor it's
these right here this is a [ __ ] para
military style hat all right this is
something that a contractor would wear
and uh this would be a good pliskan hat
but the thing is is i think
a black condor hat is 20 a pop just for
the hat
so that means after shipping and doing
an image on it you might be talking 40
for a hat like that i don't know if it's
i don't know if people be interested in
the price that high
we'll see
i hate those damn hats they have the
nylon backs and it looks like back in
the 70s and the with the cheap material
and the trucker had i can't stand those
well the trucker hats i kind of feel
like they're more like kind of puffy
yeah puffy puff [ __ ] puffy in the back
those were those were kind of popular
for a minute like what back in the like
the early 2000s i want to say everybody
was all about the trucker hats well i
wasn't but you know
uh oracle said we need to talk about
food that's tradition
uh tom made chicken biryani in the
instant pot today yeah yes it came out
good it did it was delicious it came out
good i can do it better next time but it
came out pretty good
now this is not the first thing
that's not the first thing we made the
instant pot because you made something
else in it
you made chicken with salad at the other
thing is those that wasn't pressure
cooked and that was okay brianna was
pressure cooked
only pressure cooked for six minutes and
then and then
six minutes and then five minutes
that's uh because you had to do the
chicken first and then i added the rice
and then pressure cooked the rice for
five minutes and when it came out it was
done
yeah that instant pot was that whole
chicken pretty awesome that was that
whole chicken i quartered it and put it
in there
uh what edible garden plants are you
guys planting oh man all kinds of
broccoli
there's melons out there squash
tomatoes
uh got a bunch of herbs coming like
basil cilantro
uh i got trees coming i got an avocado
tree
i got a lemon tree
um
that's it for right now i'm going to get
some other [ __ ] maybe i'll get some
oranges
that would be good actually i love one
yeah
um thank you jeffy art jenny good call
with the movie spring i actually really
did like that movie a lot watched it on
2b and now found my new valentine's day
tradition and i hate valentine's day
that's why i said in the review i said
even if you don't like
love stories
um
give that movie a shot because it is
technically a love story but she's a
monster so
it's actually it's a little bit
lovecraftian too so it's kind of cool
tina's hasn't anybody seen eaten alive
i did a long time ago the toby hooper
one right yeah yeah
uh john smith says speaking of unsolved
mysteries anyone else loved that old
show unsolved mysteries that used to
genuinely scare oh yeah yeah oh yeah did
we do we did an episode we did an
episode like a tribute yeah to unsolved
mysteries because
man i used to i used to watch that as a
kid and like just even the the theme
music was creepy
like robert stack his voice was creepy
and
man some of the [ __ ] they featured on
there because they did paranormal [ __ ]
too
cheryl's uh prepping veggies for shrimp
and sausage jambalaya right now yeah
that sounds good yeah jambalaya is not
similar to brianni that's like an indian
version of jambalaya they're kind of
similar
jenny needs an orange tree so she never
runs out of orange juice
yeah well we'll see
i mean we might get one like i said
it's funny my uh
where i used to live in daytona beach or
holly hill
my grandma's house she had an orange
tree in the backyard
but the oranges back there they'd kind
of gone wild
so
they were still oranges technically but
they were very sour
you could still you could technically
make lemonade with it because it kind of
tasted like lemons what would probably
grow better would be tangerines
now tangerines are very good too yeah
tangerines grow really well though i
know that they grow real well here i've
seen wild before
i put put some tangerines out there and
i see i want it to be kind of look like
a park out there with little pathways
and [ __ ]
once it's all done because all that [ __ ]
sprinklered it's got sprinklers down the
whole thing
so i can plant in there you know but i
don't want it to look like food
production i don't want to look at like
my [ __ ]
grandparents as [ __ ] mississippi
[ __ ]
uh uh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
like the [ __ ] subsistence farmers
well you wanted to look aesthetically
it's gotta be systemically pleasing yeah
but you also wanted to like grow some
food yeah people were saying boy you
could put a pool out there look
you do not want a [ __ ] swimming pool
i mean i do
but i don't want to take care of it
everybody know that i has one said it's
a huge mistake they are a pain in the
ass huge well the thing about it i mean
in florida you're gonna have alligators
in them that's literally you go out
there in this damn alligator in your
pool or the deer the deer are in there i
don't really care about the deer but the
deer will go in there and take a bath
and then come back out well hey what you
have if you have a pool you gotta put a
fence around it
and uh putting a fence around this place
would cost a lot of money
well yeah because well yeah that we have
we have laws about you have to have like
a certain certain kinds of fans because
they don't want people's like [ __ ]
kids like wandering and they're drowning
right because that does happen quite a
lot well no you will you need to have a
fence around here regardless yeah i'd
have to put it around the whole thing
the whole property
because alligators leaving the pond
they'll [ __ ]
they'll go a long way people don't
realize that alligator will [ __ ]
journey for miles they'll just mosey all
over the [ __ ] place and they'll take
a rest man
in somebody's swimming pool they'll
that's like the hotel
it's like the hotel they're like i'm
gonna spend the night here
it's like alligator vacation yeah
it's on the news all the time and we're
not talking about five foot alligators
we're talking about 12 foot 11 foot
[ __ ] monsters yeah because how many
[ __ ] videos have you seen of like
people in florida like waking up in the
morning and going out in their kitchen
to make some coffee and being like oh
there's an alligator in the pool got to
call animal control yeah most of them
are four or five feet long
but you don't really notice them that's
not a big deal
it's the monsters that are out there
they got [ __ ] huge ones
they do yeah
and around here because this is
kind of rural
um
[Music]
you know not as rural as it looks
between towns i mean if you see a if you
see
a shot of this place from from the air
it's surrounded by everything you know
you walk in any direction longer than
[ __ ] four or five miles you'll run
into a road
but um every
it's
if you look at florida from space at
night with the lights on the whole
thing's just lit up like a damn
christmas tree it would make you think
that that it's just one big city like
it's all new york it's not
all that shit's [ __ ]
deceptive they're shooting they're
shooting it with light magnification
over time to get a [ __ ] brighter
image um
but
just [ __ ] just just [ __ ] go on google
earth and look at the map i mean there's
roads everywhere
yeah it's like the thing about it is
like there's rural patches but you don't
really have to drive more than a few
miles
before right there's something i mean
it's not necessarily a city because look
at like look at where my mom and my
parents live my stepdad lived that's
kind of enforced in the middle of
nowhere well that that's ocala national
forest yeah which is like a big like
acres and acres and acres and miles and
miles of nothing
um but trees and you'll go down
but they even but even they have like a
gas station and like there's a walmart a
couple miles away and that's something
funny you'll see an indian restaurant
[Laughter]
pizza place well like i said it was
really weird like when we first moved
here because
you know where we live like i said it's
this neighborhood and then across the
street is a farm
and then there's a dollar general
literally next to
this
neighborhood yeah and then you can go up
the street about a mile
mile and a half something like that and
then there's like a strip mall and the
strip mall has a publix a liquor store a
dominoes a dominoes
a diner like a breakfast ice cream place
an ice cream a coffee place yeah and a
japanese restaurant yeah that's great
which is actually really really good
yeah you can go in there and give
[ __ ] there's a hair place too like a
hair like a hair cutting you can get all
the different kinds of dragon rolls and
sushi rolls yeah we've eaten at that
japanese place like a lot of that
yeah i mean for being out here i don't
think it's japanese people i think it's
chinese people working there but all the
all the waitresses are
oriental you know [ __ ] asian that's
what we call i think they're chinese
though
but the [ __ ] the shit's good the food
in there is really good i've been all
over you know it's you know i've been uh
[ __ ] new york and [ __ ] lived in
boston i'm from california
also as a little kid and
um it's not like it was back in the 80s
you know where you had to be in a big
city to get good food this shit's a
diaspora now
everybody
knows what good food tastes like now
it's everywhere
it's just not like it was
like i've heard people [ __ ] ask
questions you know
like uh some of my aunts in [ __ ]
california well what's the culture like
what's the food like in in in
florida you know and she lives in vista
vista california and it just
she still thinks it's [ __ ] 1981.
you know
[ __ ] it
it's all about the same no matter where
you go
yeah to be honest it's kind of like
yeah there's probably like some really
really little rural places where you
can't get good
mexican food or indian food or whatever
but you just drive a hour i mean yeah
honestly nowadays it really seems like
it's not
that much of a thing anymore yeah like
some things are easier to get than
others but
like i said the fact that we kind of
live
in a pretty rural like farm area and yet
a mile away there's like a really really
good like sushi restaurant
let's be honest man [ __ ]
but when it comes to income and
development
in the united states bottom of the
barrel is mississippi all right so i go
down there
to see my dad when he's going through
all those surgeries
go through hattiesburg mississippi go to
go to a chinese restaurant that was
looked like it was run by
they're probably i don't know
vietnamese is probably who it was
running it
and i had the best [ __ ] general
chicken i've ever had in that [ __ ]
little place and fit
you know
and then
everything's there and [ __ ] fantastic
mexican food
he was like what the [ __ ] is mexican
food doing in mississippi
yeah back in 81 man you couldn't get
good mexican food back in 88 you
couldn't get good mexican food in
mississippi
but sanderson farms chickens there now
you know a lot of mexicans and central
americans moved there to work at
sanderson's farms chicken
mexicans are all over
central mississippi
and
the best restaurants that are there
right now in central mississippi and
certain some some towns is a mexican
restaurant
because that's where the money is
well yeah there's a lot of there's no a
lot of kids will eat it and so will all
the white people come and eat it well
there's a lot of good mexican
restaurants around here too because a
lot of there's a lot of mexicans working
working in here around here yeah so it's
not like it used to be just uh 500
meters
in that direction over there is a cattle
farm but it had to be two or three
hundred head of cattle sitting there
i'm gonna go investigate see if i can
buy a cow
i don't have the freezer space once it's
slaughtered
well
we got
central americans some of them are
mexican but i think most of them are
places like guatemala venezuela
which those used to be part of mexico at
one time long time ago
because they had their own little
central civil wars that happened and
breakaway republics and [ __ ] happened
back in the 1800s but
they're here
and in florida they got kind of pretty
strict rules so
they're all um legal workers a lot of
them are migrants or they're here on
work permits and they're
working in these farms
and because of that they got to pay them
so they got money
you know they sent a lot of it home
but they got to live when they're here
man one of the best [ __ ] mexican
markets just up this [ __ ] road here
they got a great mexican restaurant
right in there it's big it's a
restaurant and a grocery store and a
grocery store yeah like half and half i
go in there man i'm a [ __ ] like the
only white dude in there
you know if i could eat and [ __ ]
the people that run it you know speak
fluent english and spanish
they've been here forever they've been
here for 15 [ __ ] years
white dude sits down next to me he's
ordering all kinds of sicknesses man
this just really good [ __ ] no i
blessed me
oh yeah i forgot
mexico has white people too yeah
so you know let that be a listen to you
let it be a lesson yeah they don't all
look like indians you know it's like a
[ __ ] from mexico city you know
they look as white as jenny
you know that's pretty white pretty
[ __ ] boy
grandpa's hammer says true story
grantham once served because he's
referring to himself in the third person
like since that show
makes it bigger more sure once served an
arrest warrant on a guy rolling sushi
rolls for his restaurant while his
long-haired cat licked at the rice in a
big wooden bowl oh [ __ ]
yeah honestly if i was just eating it i
don't think i would be father me and
jenny last night me and jenny were in
bed eating pringles
she had a can of pringles i had her had
a can of pringles she had the damn
vinegar the salt and vinegar ones i had
the [ __ ] pizza flavor
pookie jumps up and asked for a [ __ ]
[ __ ] she's like can i have one of those
i give her a pringle she loved it she's
like oh she ate a whole [ __ ] pringle
i had to break it up
yeah it's pretty good i mean i'm not
gonna lie she rarely and i've seen you
do it too like sometimes you'll break
off like a piece of food for her to eat
and you put it down and she'll kind of
lick it or like take a bite or something
she'll leave it there i've seen you pick
that [ __ ] up and eat it
that was like little things like cookies
and [ __ ] like that
but she didn't really eat it she just
licked it that's what i mean i'm not
honestly she's not dirty
i'm not concerned
um my tongue just brushed it just yeah
i know some people might be grossed out
if you don't have a cat or a dog um i
brush my hair with the same brush that
she like i'll brush her with it and then
brush my hair
yeah
and it's like you know that cat smells
good
she has never smelled bad that kid yeah
and it'll smell like [ __ ] uh baby
shampoo she smells like baby powder baby
powder baby shampoo
basic smells like that too yeah
i've never had i mean honestly yeah i
kind of feel like
if you have a cat that stinks there's
probably something
wrong with that cat like it's sick or
or it lives in a house that is not clean
yeah because cats if left to their own
devices are
rather clean animals
they don't stink like like dogs kind of
stink
um not always but i mean cats
if they're properly cared for don't
stink yeah
if they're healthy she's talking about
she wants good chinese food she'll go to
chinatown yeah we got
we do have good chinese food here
oh there's a chinese restaurant up there
too there's already like chinese chinese
yeah the chinese restaurant's just okay
it's pretty it's it's pretty good it's
possible just for chinese takeout i mean
right
i've had better i've had works there's a
place to go to called koi won
and uh [ __ ] that's 20 miles from here
now we've moved quite a nuts further
probably 30 now but it's a buffet it's
like going to chinese disneyland it's
got a [ __ ]
koi pond and a river that runs down
through the middle of the restaurant
with [ __ ] chinese [ __ ] bridges
that go over it and
uh yeah all you can eat sushi and all
you can eat rolls and
you can pay extra and get all you need
crab legs and
shrimp and everything and i'll go in
there i won't touch a bit of rice i'll
eat nothing but just the meat and
vegetables man i'll tear it up get a
good meal in there
but it's probably only about
i think daytime is about ten dollars
right all you can eat and i think night
i think it's gone up slightly but not
that much i think it's like maybe 11 or
12 now but you can eat as much as you
want
dinner times probably about 15 to 17.
something like that and if you start
throwing in [ __ ] like all you can eat
crab legs it's gonna be about 20 bucks
but still i mean still it's a good deal
20-something bucks
and uh koi won is a good one
but they have the all the little sushi
rolls and crab rolls and they're making
them right there so
they got nice [ __ ] here
you know
um
it's good i just think it's funny you
know some of my relatives in california
think that there's only good food in
california it's about like that
everywhere now well i mean at some point
probably yeah it used to be in the 80s
there was only good food in big cities i
see it that was in the 80s though but
nowadays it's really kind of
proliferated because like i said
everybody probably had to do like the
internet because everybody is a [ __ ]
foodie now so you can't get away with
like shitty ass food anymore there's a
place up here called texas to brazil
which is korea brazilian korea it's um
not eustis it's uh
mount dora no
uh
stanford no up north
which i remember it was i've been having
been there in about 10 years
trying to think where the [ __ ] that
pokemon well that's there's more than
one of those right
yeah the one that i went to was up there
not eustis but uh
it's right outside eustis
and uh it's sorrento no
[ __ ] i see it on the map
um i think it's about 20 something bucks
to eat there
and it was nice
and uh
at that
shaskar is all you can eat brazilian
barbecue go right to the bathroom and
it's kind of like uh
gaucho style
but brazilian gaussian
and that food there was every bit as
good it was just as authentic as it was
in sao paulo brazil it was [ __ ] great
people would have loved that restaurant
in brazil but it had everything fought
off fania
it had um
all the uh
the different cuts of [ __ ]
meat that they would only have in brazil
like the hump of the brahma bull i think
they call it what they call that bistaka
i forgot what they called it
they had a lot they had every cut
and these gauchos would come up with a
sword
with the [ __ ] pieces of meat on it
put it in your plate
and with a gaucho knife [ __ ] cut that
[ __ ] off and just
lay slabs of meat
on your plate and then walk off
it was good man [ __ ] they come to the
whole damn sort of [ __ ]
chicken hearts
i remember when i first had those things
i was in brazil you know i had one i
said oh that's good and i just kept
asking for more i had a whole plate of
these little things
and i was the kid you know my mom was i
didn't know you like chicken hearts and
because those are chicken hearts and
those and they're like yeah yeah they're
good
real good
i need about [ __ ] 10 20 of them damn
chicken hearts
but they'd have pork and beef and
chicken and [ __ ]
they had weird cuts
that you wouldn't eat in the united
states like tongue
but it was just beautiful
if you weren't really if you didn't know
what it was like tongue you you'd still
eat it's like ham you know kind of like
a ham type or beef type flavor it was
good
and then they had uh
real good [ __ ] alcoholic drinks like
you know caipinha
which was
it's kashasa with [ __ ]
crushed lemon and sugar oh kashasa is
kind of like
brazilian everclear that shit's [ __ ]
deadly man
really good
i can remember it man carnival
memories
yeah
rebecca i took jenny there man i took
jenny there she'd like it i think
i probably would
now my friends that are still there are
telling me not to go they said
that that it's not as good as it was
when we were kids
because the economy nothing ever is well
they said the economy is so bad the
economy is terrible there now
rebecca says i went to a chinese
restaurant in antwerp belgium it was
disgusting i have no idea what it was
but my bro in law is originally from
hong kong and he cooks i know what they
certainly wasn't chinese i do kind of
feel like well nothing in the west is
chinese well that's true but i mean if
you see what they're eating in china you
would need that
yeah we had a friend who was
uh
culturally chinese and she went back to
china like she'd never been before but
she went back let's like her uh
her uh ancestry was that so she went to
china and when she came back one of the
first things she said was yeah chinese
food weed here that's nothing like this
she's like this [ __ ] to eat
[Laughter]
a lot of the real famous chinese dishes
that are real well known here are
actually from taiwan and they come out
of damn taiwan
taiwanese [ __ ] five-star hotels
they're copies
of five-star hotel recipes
aimed towards foreigners
chicken [ __ ] chinese people eat a lot
of [ __ ] like chicken feet
and you know terrible meat not much
there they'll eat bugs
uh they'll just you wouldn't eat that
that kind of stuff but it's
the first the first iterations of
american chinese food came out of san
francisco where tea lives
and they they used to play jokes you
know on the white folks
chop suey and [ __ ] which is basically
just damn table scraps they would just
[ __ ] serve the white people table
scraps here take that
that's not what the chinese were
and the whole chinese
restaurant
thing game in the united states and it
went into europe too it spread into
europe
it was more about chinese people selling
products to white people
well that's what it was when they were
smart
yeah because they wouldn't
we wouldn't eat what they would eat a
lot of times so they made up stuff for
us that we would eat
well yeah it's just more tailored to
right yeah a western palette is what
they were doing
and honestly because that's what i would
do as a chef so they're not i mean you
should because if you make a lot of
stuff that people don't want to eat no
one's going to eat it and you're going
to go broke so you better make some [ __ ]
that people want to eat
the thing about it though is i think
like a lot of i don't know if this is
the case anymore but a lot of chinese
restaurants back in the day they'd kind
of have if you were moving here and
wanted to open a chinese restaurant
there was kind of like there were
companies that would help you it's like
look we have you know this rest this is
the menu it's already like made ahead of
time and they already have like a menu
template set up and all of the business
plan like already set up for you so you
basically just have it's like
franchising but it wasn't
you know it wasn't like mcdonald's or
anything like that but it was like a
franchise type situation and that's why
if you go to like a lot of chinese
takeout places even still like to this
day um
their menus
look the same like their printed menus
are the same like the dishes are pretty
much the same and are made the same way
um and you can go to different ones and
they all taste
pretty much the same
so that's why because it's almost kind
of like a franchising type of thing that
they do um let me see
oh i saw something earlier that like
made me laugh uh granthar says my 11
month old brittany puppy eats her own
turds just seconds after she drops them
see this is why look i l i love dogs i
do but uh i never really wanted one
because dogs i mean people say cats are
gross but i mean dogs are
kind of gross in the sense that they'll
eat their own poop they'll eat cat poop
they'll eat anything pretty much um
i don't think either of our cats has
ever eaten their own poop not that i'm
aware of they do barf every now and then
but
that's it's gross but it's not that
gross i've never seen them like eat
their own poop they seem pretty like
pretty not although the funny thing
about it is that pookie
will watch beijing poop and beijing is
like not hi puke i was talking about you
um
oh cause she made it i made a noise i
made a noise
she's like so she likes to pretend
that her life is full of like drama
i guess because it's not really like
she's she has a very easy life
um you know everybody is like sweet to
her everybody pets her she just gets to
sleep all day but she likes to pretend
that she lives this life of like
excitement and intrigue so like every
time somebody like comes in the room or
makes a noise she's like
she like makes this big [ __ ] dramatic
[ __ ] thing about it you're such a
drama queen pook
but yeah so she has this weird thing
where like if beijing uses the litter
box
pookie will like go in there and like
watch her
chick is like you can tell that beijing
is just kind of like oh my god i can't
believe it's happening right now like
she's very
embarrassed about it but pookie is like
completely shameless it's like it's
[ __ ] hilarious like watching the two
of them but um
uh tila says my cats eat sauteed spinach
and kale odd kitties yeah i'm trying to
think of like i had a cat
uh when i was younger
who
uh she was like a black and white kitty
and she lived on our porch
and she
loved
donuts like no specifically she loved
you know those little d little debbie
like donut sticks
she was super into those which
i don't know why but she really really
liked those she also really kind of like
potato chips yeah so
i do think that there's something maybe
they do because i i don't think cats
usually like sweet things they don't
really have they don't taste it they
don't taste anything sweet so which is
weird because i had a potato sauce like
i said i had a cat that really liked
doughnuts i don't really know why but
yeah so i think salty they do kind of
cause um beijing likes parmesan cheese
if you put like a little pile of
parmesan they just stinks they like
anything else yeah they like anything
that smells like feet so they like kind
of cheese stuff or they like fishy nasty
stinky yeah the stinkier it is like the
happier they are they don't have much
taste buds at all really it's more smell
yeah and for some reason they just kind
of
now getting back to food
and the differences
we got uh there are some things
that you can't get in florida
that you can only get in some bigger
cities all right especially new york
we have a lot of friends here that are
from new york the new york city area
pizza
here is corporate pizza
domino's
pizza hut papa john's papa john's little
caesars
you don't have
small
mom pop there are some they went out of
business a lot of them yeah
now was there was that one good one by
the starbucks over there on 434 yeah
um that pizza place was decent they in
general can't stay in business yeah
and it's just because you don't have
pizza connoisseurs here people don't
care
uh if it's papa john's or little caesars
or [ __ ]
pizza hut that's that's the pizza that
they know i mean i'll eat dominoes or
pizza hut or papa john's in a pinch i
mean your pizza is obviously way better
yeah but if we don't feel like cooking i
don't i'm not averse to ordering it's
not terrible i don't like little caesars
though if you were to give a new york
style pizza to you know like something
from a pizzeria
to a to a floridian
that was raised on papa john's and
[ __ ]
you know pizza hut they would just taste
that and they go that's not real good
they would just
think
they wouldn't ask for that again they
wouldn't throw it away
just that they would they wouldn't see a
big enough difference
they'd just call [ __ ] pizza hut
again now i know better you know what i
mean i've
i can i make my own and i can appreciate
everything you know and i can go to i
can go when i went to new york i had
some of the
some of the pizzeria pizza in there and
it was
it was good it was good i still think
mine's a little bit better but
the way they're doing is a lot of times
depending on where they are a lot of
them are cooking it on a [ __ ]
on a metal mesh
well they have to do like a much larger
volume they're cut they're cooking out
of
volume so that's gonna
inch down though yeah so there are there
are some old school style italian pizzas
tastes like something out of the 70s
that are still out there
that a corporation can't replicate i
could replicate it
some of those guys might be dealing with
[ __ ] special yeasts
like dough cultures that have been saved
that's another factor
but uh no you're not gonna find that
here so you do have some italians
italians from the new york area that
show up here and they love it but they
go man you can't get a good pizza no
no but let me tell you if you're that
much of a [ __ ] guido
that is that that's putting you out that
much you'll learn how to [ __ ] make a
pizza
a real man can make a [ __ ] pizza i'm
not going to tell you not to make a
[ __ ] pizza all right
so stop with that [ __ ] goat
you do make very good yeah
yeah and i'm not even italian but
[ __ ] i can make a [ __ ] badass
pizza and [ __ ] so could you make your
own [ __ ] pizzeria thing is if you
open up a pizza right here they won't
appreciate it
go out of business
although every single person that has
eaten your pizza has said
you should open a restaurant because
it's so much better than every other
pizza which it is yeah your location
location location right i would not want
to run a restaurant you'd have to be in
a [ __ ] badass location yeah i mean
that's the market is not here for that
remember deep dish his [ __ ]
a friend of mine he's called him deep
dish he's a big old fat greek guy who
ran down pizzeria around around the club
it's around the corner
it's still there it's been there for
[ __ ] 30 odd years i think yeah
because everybody eats there after the
bar closes because it's open it's good
pizza but it's not compared to it's good
it's not great yeah it's not great it's
just good yeah and it's good yeah it's
not
for new york
it would be substandard
they would go oh no it's not because you
know they're not getting there yeah
they're like oh there's problems with
their sicilians pretty decent gotta say
yeah and the white pizza is good yeah i
like the white pizza that has spinach
yeah but it's not it's not in a [ __ ]
basically a [ __ ] 600 degree kiln
that's not how they're cooking i mean
it's a tiny ass place right they're
basically catering just like that taco
place that was across the street they're
catering to drunks yeah uh like i said
they stay open all night they're right
around the corner from like all of the
major bars
so
everybody goes there after the bars
close you go to the pizza place and you
get pizza yeah and it's
it's good actually it's good it's better
than
most of the delivery places it is better
pizza than that i'll give them that
it's not the best pizza i've ever eaten
but it's better than
you know it's better than a little sauce
in new york are better than pizza hut
her other new york friend who moved to
here is [ __ ] imani
and she couldn't tell you anything about
food she's got the [ __ ] palette of a
five-year-old child
that [ __ ] would [ __ ] eat a [ __ ]
cold hot dog that's what she grew up on
hot the cold hot dogs i did too but it
just you know i mean when i was little
she didn't give her good food she
wouldn't know the difference i tried to
give her some indian food she's like oh
no
[Laughter]
and that's what we took are the memories
of india and she's too sophisticated for
her
so you can't you got chicken tea you
can't you can't stereotype everybody i
mean some people can come from a big
city and they're provincial as [ __ ] they
don't know anything outside the yeah
well it's it's not really so much like
the place you came from is like the
family the family right
because
right i mean if you grew up and your
parents didn't like give you anything
give you nothing yeah then but the thing
about it though is that you can grow out
of that because i grew up
you know quite poor and i grew up like a
really picky eater
you know i ate my share cold hot dogs
when i was a kid too
um and i was like oh i don't like this i
don't like that i don't like tomatoes i
don't like mushrooms i don't like
anything like that and i was very very
picky but i got over it yeah uh so
you know if if you want to you will yeah
and you know okay this is that's right
tom a real man can make pizza of course
a real gangster can make pizza
tila also said i remember my parents
taking me to a chinese restaurant when i
was about three years old i asked for
french fries yeah they were struggle
fries but i ate them lol yeah honestly
the um
koi wan it's mostly like chinese food
they but they have like other [ __ ] too
it's a buffet so they have other [ __ ]
like jello and salads
and like yeah on the other side if you
bring like your little kids they have
french fries chicken nuggets pizza [ __ ]
like that because you know how kids are
they won't [ __ ] eat they have
hamburgers and although i get i don't
have kids so i don't really know um
how this works out because i kind of
feel like i hate that way as a kid well
that's what i'm saying because i do kind
of feel like a lot of american parents
are like oh you know kids it's like all
they want to eat is spaghetti and
chicken nuggets and blah blah blah but
the thing about it one of my friends had
a daughter
and
she gave her like weird ass food like
from the jump and that kid would eat all
kind of weird [ __ ]
so i kind of feel like maybe it's not
necessarily i mean and maybe it has to
do with like the individual kid because
some obviously some kids are probably
pickier than others but i kind of feel
like this whole thing like kids will
only eat chicken nuggets blah blah that
might have to do with
what you expose them to yeah but i don't
know i don't have kids so i'm not like
judging me i want eggs benedict and
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that and [ __ ]
omelets and you know
[Laughter]
i wanted i yeah yeah i can i liked it i
liked good food
as a kid
that's what i'm saying i've noticed i've
known both i've known some parents that
were kind of like we tried to introduce
them to like all these different foods
but they did all they wanted was chicken
nuggets yeah but then i've known some
people that had kids that were like no
we you know we just ate they ate
whatever we ate
so they didn't have this weird thing
where they only had to eat kid food but
so i guess it depends on the kid to some
extent yeah um but as soon as i was old
enough to talk i'd be pointed [ __ ]
with those adults right now let me get
some of that let me get some of that
i've heard i've been getting that
getting some people that had kids say oh
yeah they're like if you want your kids
to eat like weird [ __ ] or exotic [ __ ] or
like not have to you know make something
special for the kids because they won't
eat what you're eating
um tell them that what you're eating oh
that's just for adults that's not for
you and then they'll want it yeah it's
like reverse segments
let me have some money it kind of
reminds me
i went back to mississippi one time i
was probably about
22 23 i was in the army at the time
and my little cousin
he was about [ __ ] seven
he ended up being in [ __ ] the navy
and then they in in the during their
during the iraq wars he's in the navy
and they attach him to the 101st
airborne division as infantry you see
he's getting navy medals and [ __ ]
army medals at the same as the weirdest
[ __ ] he was in
yeah he was army and navy at the same
time and being infantry even though he
was like on some kind of radar
specialist that's how how much they were
hurt anyway
he's like seven
and i'm helping him fill his plate
you know i mean at the [ __ ]
the the thanksgiving buffet
so i'm putting stuff on his plate for
him you know
and he goes
and he points to the [ __ ]
black olives that were in a little
[ __ ]
bowl all right he goes
and he and he's pointed those you want
somebody i want give me a certain black
balls
it's a black balls
yeah give me some black balls this is
this is alice
and he says you ever had any of them and
he's like nah
so as soon as i put her on his plate he
reaches over there and [ __ ] takes
pics
picks up that [ __ ] black olive it's
pitted you know yeah it didn't have pits
in it
he picks up that blackout and puts it in
and it's like he was being electrified
that is also my reaction to eating a
black olive
i'm not a fan he liked it though i'm not
a fan of black olives
it's like he's getting ready to fall
over and i'm grabbing his plate and [ __ ]
all right he's coming to join hillary
yeah
pretty funny did you like that yeah yeah
i'm not sure what just happened but i
enjoyed it
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] funny i don't like
black olives though oh
because you love them yeah um
i'll eat them but it's not i i kind of
feel like i'm at the point of my life
like i said back when i was a kid there
was a lot of [ __ ] i would not eat
because i was like super super picky
it's like no i don't want that no i
don't want that nowadays i'm kind of
like i don't really have that strong of
feelings about anything
um unless it's like something really
[ __ ] out there
um you know black olives i'd rather not
but if they're on it i'm i'll eat them
i'm not going to complain about it but
you know i'd rather not have it on there
but you know i'll eat it it's fine
yeah so it's it's just kind of like like
steven's laughing at black boss yeah
black ball yeah i [ __ ] with him every
time i see him he wants me in black
balls
i still remember remember that [ __ ] he's
like yeah man i'm hollers or something
else he said
i kind of you know what's weird i asked
him years later when he was old enough
to [ __ ] like answer me or like what
it was and he says they had a metallic
taste
they do a bit so that's what made him
[ __ ] they do a bit electrify
yeah
they do taste a bit metallic though
that's actually like pretty personal
they tasted real metallic yeah they do
kind of it's like it was shocking me
that's what he said like
he said it was like a nine-volt battery
yeah yeah yeah so like i said i'm not a
big fan of olives um
i'll eat them but
you know if if you ask me do you want
them or not i'd be like no no thanks but
if they're on there already i'm not
going to make a stink about them like
yeah i'll eat them it's fine you know
what i mean i've kind of gotten to that
i'm just i'm just zen about it
there's very few things that i'm just
like absolutely not i'm not gonna eat
that i'll just i'll eat pretty much
anything i don't wanna buy the anchovy
pizzas i've never had them
i just the smell of an anchovy would
have
honestly i'm not averse to anchovies
because i don't know if you know this
but in a lot of salad dressings even
ones they sell like at the grocery store
they have anchovies in them yeah and i
don't know so if you're a vegan you
might want to like look at i'm sure you
probably already know but you might want
to look at the ingredients because they
do put anchovy in a lot of salad
dressings without really gotta
advertising that fact gotta send out a
signed copy of the of the hardcover
the hardcover cookbook
to my boy
okay
well let me write that down oh somebody
asked me today too i got an email today
somebody wanted
uh autographed copies of all my faceless
villain books oh [ __ ] i gotta do that
right so i gotta like [ __ ] well i
wrote that down over there if you guys
need a cookbook cookbook just uh
drop something in the chats here and
we'll contact you after the show's over
how much is a cookbook
uh i'd have to look and i think they're
about 15 bucks no it's 30 something
30-something bucks
well they're hardback they're hardcover
they're hard back and they're full color
yeah full color full bleed all right oh
[ __ ] we'll send you we'll send you
the link to where to buy them [ __ ]
snatchy but uh it's a good cookbook it's
got everything everything we talk about
a bunch of different food kind of food
southern food brazilian food
uh foreign food and i get done indian
food indian food thai food and i get
down to even making [ __ ] like condiments
so if you're in a country where you
can't get the stuff
like my friend saw it in saudi arabia
i think he got it he was making pecan
pie out of it [ __ ] it up
he didn't use the right [ __ ]
you got to [ __ ] make because he was
going to make pecan pie for his mom and
then [ __ ] once he got it done in
[ __ ]
oh because uh he didn't use um well you
can't i mean you know i've had that
habit you got to use the right [ __ ]
kind of corn syrup or you got to use uh
um
what do you call it
maple syrup one of the two
and he thought he had a an arabian
equivalent to that no you can't you
can't substitute
but
pecan pie
is in the arabic flavor palette that's
like yeah he loved how he ate it anyway
it just didn't hold together
but um that's okay well like a few times
when i made like brownies and it didn't
really come out good and it was kind of
like too runny and stuff i'm like oh
well i'm just gonna like put it in a
bowl with vanilla ice cream yeah it's a
win yeah
still tastes good but if you're arabic
and you've never had uh
pecan pie
you would love pecan pie especially with
a scoop of [ __ ] vanilla ice cream on
it
or whipped cream well i mean to be
honest a lot of like this southern food
flavor profile is
going back a generation or two an
african
yeah flavor profile it's very
africanized or it has like a lot of
african influence
so man they'll come out and say like you
know we go we go down to [ __ ] the
soul food restaurant here and they're
going to call it soul food and i'm going
this is just mississippi food
basically
chantal
yeah
chantelle's i go there it's just like a
regular restaurant to me you know what i
mean because well because that was even
though i am i mean i'm white yeah but we
ate that same food pretty much i mean i
grew up in the south my uh my dad's side
of the table southern they were
tennessee
so
they just ate
essentially what would be called soul
food right collard greens
all the same kind of stuff fried okra
fried ochre all the same kind of stuff
that was all what we ate and all that
stuff yeah and then the new uh innovate
the in the new innovations [ __ ] like
chicken and waffles
i never had it but as soon as i had it i
was like oh oh yeah of course
he made chicken and wine
yeah oh it's good it's like oh yeah
of course
[Laughter]
chicken and waffles is one of the best
things ever that is one of those
seriously one of the best combos ever so
you could call that soul food and you
could also call that [ __ ]
food in the deep south my grandmother
would have loved that
that was right there within that palette
within that same flavor palette
just that that didn't come out during
her lifetime
yeah although i never could reverse her
ass from [ __ ] overcooking a goddamn
[ __ ] spinach
over cooking [ __ ] my grandma did that
too
overcooking spinach and overcooking pork
chops yeah pork chops until they were
just [ __ ]
like [ __ ]
jerky [ __ ] terrible i told you before
i thought i hated pork chops my whole
entire life you ever cook them
yeah because they were like so
overcooked and they were saying i'm like
man pork sucks
uh yeah no not so much
we've gotten pork chops you've made pork
chops oh yeah in the crock pot and [ __ ]
like that and they were [ __ ]
succulent and delicious but yeah it
depends on how i'm going to do it back
then they worried about well
they're worried about trichinosis you
know yeah they were worried about
trypnosis even though that wasn't even a
thing back then that had already been
eradicated it had been eradicated by the
time the 70s had come around but they
were just scared of it yeah i get it
yeah but you know and yeah people
you can buy a piece of pork
you can you can eat medium rare pork it
is safe yeah it's fine um
would you want to it depends on the dish
yeah i mean you can't just say like no
across the board right i probably would
but like i said it would depend on what
the district i don't know what the dish
is
um
we were talking about like uh i was
talking about pokey watching beijing
pope in the litter box yeah watching it
come out and everything and tila said my
cats will watch us poop if you don't
close the bathroom door yeah yeah if i
cause my bathroom right there has two
doors it has one door from here and then
one door into the hallway
sometimes if i come in here to pee in
the middle of the night i will just
close the door from the hall and not
close the door to my office and if
pookie is in here she will run and be
like what you doing and then like you
know you're sitting there peeing like
she's like looking at you going huh yeah
and it's not just that animals
animals are biological
they can relate to you they they commune
if your hat if you're going to the
bathroom they want to yeah they just
want to make it like that i do that too
right yeah
and they understand sex if you have sex
they want to watch that and they want to
have yeah grantharis was saying that
about how like the puppy was like yeah
yeah
pookie gets like she gets like upset
like
i don't know
sometimes no is this supposed to be
going on does she think that like
someone's getting hurt
[Laughter]
she seems a little weirder it's just
that cat um because
my ex-wife
i mean
we had two cats
and that [ __ ] would be [ __ ] going
down and both cats would be basically
at the edge of the foot of the bed
side by side laying down paying homage
like they were worshiping like yeah it
was like it was like a religious
experience for them they're like going
yeah yeah
yeah yes yes and then they're like
bowing down yeah
so they knew what it was
they knew exactly what it was
i don't think they understood what their
relationship to the whole thing was but
that was just some weird [ __ ]
they're watching the gods have sex
and and honoring it yes it's all good
yeah pookie seems like she doesn't
really know what to think
yeah she's kind of like
yeah
she's always kind of like
is is it okay or like am i supposed to
leave am i supposed to leave or is one
of you hurt or
yeah do i need to do something should i
show someone yeah
honestly you guys can't see it pookie
has like
crashed and fallen asleep yeah right
there she's right there oh now
now everybody's talking about soul food
and southern food
see this is chicken and waffles is
divine
god roscoe's chicken we haven't had
rascal's chicken while chicken and
waffles is so good the better the waffle
the better the piece of chicken
the better the
breading the better the [ __ ] maple
syrup
the better it gets
and the and the more real that damn
butter is
you want real
real butter of course but well yeah yeah
and you want a big thick waffle which i
didn't do last time i was a toaster
waffle [ __ ] that was still good
though i got a waffle maker
i got all the damn water well i gave you
that like [ __ ] i gave you that
that waffle iron yeah i had that from a
long time ago i'll i'll do it we'll do
it again
we'll do it again i'll make i'll make it
i've found that [ __ ] really
you just want chicken thigh really
that's really what you want it's the
easiest to cut from that to be honest
yeah the thigh is has always been my
favorite you don't need the breasts you
don't need you don't need the breasts
i'm the dark meat girl you don't need
the breast you don't need the leg you
just need the thigh yep bone chicken
thighs or
if you can get boneless that's good too
but i mean thigh is the best chicken
fight me yeah
that's always been my my favorite piece
and honestly like it's good because
nobody else seems to like the thigh so
every time you get like kfc or some [ __ ]
like everybody's like oh i want the
brass down with the legs i'm like [ __ ]
give me all the thighs and i would get
all this like no one's going to fight
with me about it because like yeah you
can have those i'm like thank you these
are clearly like the best part but okay
y'all just go on with your breasts
you're saying it's got to be canadian
syrup
i got like three or four different kinds
of syrups up in here one of them is in
glass it's a real i gotta go see what
that is
um i got like
seven or eight
of them in there because
now i know we got
got uh we got my boy graham in here
and he's like uh he's also a prepper
[ __ ]
maple syrup lasts forever
and you can do a lot with that
you can take your coffee with that yeah
you can yeah you can you can put in a
lot of like a recipe anything that calls
for like any kind of sweetening sugar or
anything right right uh you can use
maple syrup you could probably take a
piece of raw meat and put it in damn
maple syrup inside of a cup and it would
probably preserve it
for a long time probably you know
six seven days
that'd probably work
because it was almost kind of like candy
it
although i'd probably do vinegar be
safer
but i'd have to look into that
but i know that that [ __ ] lasts forever
and you need sweetness
you know so i have a bunch of it just in
case
just in case just in case you can't
cheryl says i like me some chicken tits
i like fries too like honestly like all
any kind of like chicken is good
but my favorite part since i was a child
still is the thigh
yeah i love chicken thighs
if we get like the you know how
sometimes you're too lazy to cook and
you get a publix and get like a [ __ ]
eight-piece box
of fried
chicken give me the thighs well that's
good you don't want them i like them
when it comes to fried chicken the
breast i like i really like the breast
but i like all of it it's just i know
that she likes dark meat so i give her
the [ __ ] legs are good too but thighs
are my favorite no i feel like that's
the best i mean it's dark meat but also
you get a lot of meat more than more
meat than the leg most of your chinese
foods
is die
dollar for dollar used to be the thigh
was [ __ ] the best thing going
you could get [ __ ] a great deal on
chicken thigh
especially if the bone was in
it's up to you for a lot cheaper
and prices are going up man i can't
[ __ ] believe it but well that's what
somebody's saying they're like well
because yeah it used to be back in the
old days like the wings were super cheap
yeah gone now and then now that
everybody does buffalo wings now they're
expensive so i kind of feel like maybe
thighs are going the same which was kind
of sucky because i kind of feel like we
could
we could get i mean breasts were like a
little bit more expensive but i was like
ooh get the thighs and legs because it's
cheaper
and that's i like that
i like all the dark meat but yeah
i kind of feel like now everybody's like
discovering that those actually taste
better
and so now that price is it's what it is
it's just that it's demand
people want that's what i'm saying and
there's not as much of it as that well
as i said that's kind of like the dark
side of everybody being foodies now is
that
every time there's like a new [ __ ] uh
pinterest or tick tock trend about like
a new food
and it's like oh some cheap ass like
food and you can like hack it and make
it into this like amazing thing and now
everybody's going to do that
and that's going to make the price go up
because now the demand goes up because
everybody wants that [ __ ]
i'm going to start checking at some of
these local farms
yeah we probably should i mean there's
so many might have eggs and chickens
well there's so many farms around here i
know that there's there's cattle farms i
know that there's a lot of farms around
here sell honey yeah blueberries
strawberries in season yeah um oranges
[ __ ] like that hot you know so
i don't know we we talked about it the
other day when we were driving around
like looking at all the farms around
here
chicken thighs have more flavor yeah i
agree i do like the breast i don't mind
that but
like i said if we have fried chicken
like if we get like a box of fried
chicken like from kfc or publix or
whatever i'm always gonna like eat the
thighs first
and i don't even care about the breasts
they're good but
i'll eat them but
what is it called when you soak up
collards with cornbread oh i don't know
oh i lost the [ __ ]
uh i love honey on my toast
um
yeah jeffy aaron said jenny is on point
thigh meat is so succulent yeah i mean
chicken thighs to me
that's kind of like that's the best part
that's the best part
tom made chicken biryani today in the
instant pot and
he knows that i'm into
the dark meat so he gives me a big bowl
of rice and it has like a thigh and a
leg on it
and i was just kind of like
yes
uh rebecca says wings are about three
dollars per kilogram thighs are more
expensive than breast here oh that sucks
yeah here at least for now
i'm not sure
how it's gonna go
but
usually breasts are more expensive
because more people buy breasts but
because we've gotten some really good
deals like on chicken thighs chicken
thighs legs like you get the big bag
from sam's or whatever and it was like
cheaper than the breasts but i don't
know i like thighs better
yeah captain blair says thighs and an
air fryer yummy yeah
uh candied salmon
amy says i've had homemade maple syrup
maybe by the amish in mount jackson
virginia how's that oh oh well
okay
rebecca says you should get your manure
and chicken [ __ ] for your garden the
farms might be giving it away
yeah i've been getting the [ __ ] uh
all the planting stuff is just just up
the road so i've been buying that
[ __ ] by the pack and putting it in
there
fertilizer and stuff
do you think eventually we might put a
chicken coop in the backyard over to me
we're probably we're probably not
allowed
yeah i don't think we do they just make
so much goddamn noise i don't think we'd
be allowed i think [ __ ] out of take
without our friend angel was over here
and she [ __ ] has rabbits
and i was like
rabbits
and she's like yeah get you some rabbits
and i was like i don't know if i could
kill them little things you could say
yeah you don't come on don't kill her
yeah you just get them like that
and she's got a little piece
like a pookie you can't get a little
piece of wood it's like a v and she puts
their heads in a little vinegar and
breaks their [ __ ] necks like that
because it kills them instantly
and i was like i don't know if i could
do that to a cute little animal like
this i could cut chicken's heads off
but the chickens the chickens are
[ __ ] noisy man
i don't think i could kill a rabbit i
mean if i was like starving to death
probably i could but
i don't know rabbits are too cute like i
said they're too much like a pokey i
can't yeah i can't
i mean i'm glad angel can do it but
yeah they're cute i don't know if i can
keep them cute kill them cute little
thing that's what i'm saying she's more
of a badass than me i guess yeah because
i don't think i could do that because i
used to have pet rabbits what she was
saying is
good though because they're like
they they they grow to full size to
where you can eat them within like a
month or so
i know a lot of people do have them yeah
but
and pookie's like i'm out of here you
don't really have to feed them much
she's like you guys are going to kill me
for food one day
i'm not hearing that she's not defeating
much and they're not very they're not
aggressive or anything and
just says you just and they breed like
rabbits literally
there's more of them you can eat
and you can let them go evidently they
don't run they come back which that
that's some weird [ __ ] how how is that
possible stockholm syndrome yeah i guess
so
like well i
live here
you know
so i live here so they're too cute i
just i can't eat them too cute it's like
eating a cat i'm not into it
yeah cheryl says i ain't eating any
rabbits too cute yeah
i'm kind of like i kind of draw the line
i like eating cute ass animals no
chickens do not come pet become pets
[ __ ] taking care of the farms that
i've taken care of i'd take care of them
chickens i'd kill them chickens like
they were nothing
good thing about chickens though is that
they they make unlimited eggs you just
once you have [ __ ] 15 20 chickens you
can't eat all those eggs
and honestly i could eat eggs all day
long i don't have eggs they just [ __ ]
make a [ __ ] ton of eggs
but you know
the rooster makes a lot of noise the
chickens make a lot of noise they [ __ ]
on everything they're they're
they're [ __ ] pain in the ass
you don't have to feed them much either
you can just let them go and they'll run
around and eat everything then they come
back to the chicken coop they don't go
anywhere
so like this is our house yeah they're
tripped as long as you're not killing
them up too bad then i guess they won't
run they don't know you just take one
they don't see it you know
well from their point of view yeah it's
like it's like missing 4-1-1 yeah like
one of their brethren has gone missing
and they don't know what happened to
them
weird [ __ ] happens and they don't have
chicken detectives to like figure out
what went on with that stuff weird [ __ ]
happens on these farms
i don't understand how you can do the
pigs what a lot of people will do to
pigs pigs have a pretty high
intelligence it's better than a dog they
do actually
you can take one of those pigs
and slaughter that pig in full view of
the other ones and cook that pig and
they'll be asking for the food
hey let me get some of that
i i don't understand it
and they're maybe there that's your mom
maybe you're not a sociopath they're
just like so super
like here here you go here's the guts
now they're fighting over it like that's
your mom you know they don't they don't
seem to care because the thing about it
is that i don't think pigs are dumb at
all yeah they're just evil i guess like
i said maybe they're just sociopaths
i don't
know i don't think a dog would do that
i think a dog would go no i'm not going
to eat that
uh well i don't know they were starving
but i mean dogs will eat pretty much
anything
i think of a dog's
saw you kill its friend and then you
offer that friend some of some of its
meat i don't think they'd eat it now i'm
like kind of interested like i don't
want anybody don't do that experiment
obviously because that's [ __ ] up and
ethically
repugnant
but
i wonder if they would i kind of i don't
know i guess it depends on the dog well
like i said
it's kind of like
i've never heard of it i don't well i
kind of feel like some people um if they
didn't know they would but i'm saying if
they knew i don't think they would
they might not
it wouldn't surprise me if they didn't
because i've seen like if they did
fear for what happened to some other
they would yeah i don't think they'd be
like oh that's [ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah
i mean they're not stupid yeah
they do like have a an understanding of
like what's going on around them
obviously or they wouldn't have survived
this long yeah but
i don't know
i don't really like to underestimate
uh what animals can comprehend because
they always surprise me
you know what i mean
i kind of feel like back in the old days
like people thought oh animal no they
don't know anything we can just do this
she said she doesn't do swine anymore
but she but it is delicious t you know
you eat bacon
well maybe she doesn't then she's good
is bacon swine of course bacon's fun
she's sitting up there eating potted
meat [ __ ]
said yeah eating vienna sausages and
[ __ ]
[Music]
camp guys said we pre-ranged our
chickens when we had them probably lost
half or more of our eggs got laid out in
the woods yeah um
we used to uh where i used to walk along
the trail by our old house
there was a farm there and they had like
uh what i called the chicken gang
and there was like a whole gang of
chickens
and they found
a little hole in the fence
and so they would like sneak out so they
would like hang out on the trail because
i think they like the attention from all
the people that were like jogging and
riding bikes by and whatever so they
would like come out on the trail so
every time i saw i was like what's up
chicken gang but
i don't really know
they probably like laid some eggs
outside of the [ __ ]
i don't really know i mean
i'm always kind of like inclined to
uh
give animals the benefit of the doubt i
always kind of feel like they're
probably smarter than we give them
credit for
so
i mean i still eat meat but
i don't know i
that's silver tequila and apple is
actually pretty good
well that's good yeah because we were
kind of like worried because
no here trust
why would i want to drink tequila that's
good
you remember on wednesday's show you
accidentally gave me a whole drink of
tequila yeah i had one sip and i'm like
ah
yeah
like i kind of smell it but i thought
well he wouldn't have made that mistake
oh he did make that mistake
uh cheryl says animals are smart my dog
can tell me it's amazing yeah i kind of
feel like animals are like way
smarter more cognizant than we give them
credit for
um so
i don't know
tina's a zoo that sounds nasty tom i
don't know i forgot what i said i don't
know
he forgot what he said
oracle says my cat definitely knows when
i'm feeling bad he gets extra snuggly
yeah yeah pookie is
human-like in the sense that
she knows what your mood is
um she knows
i don't know she's very kid-like
and i've had cats before
and i realized that they were smart
but i think before we had pookie i
didn't really realize how actually like
smart and human-like like cats could be
she kind of has a whole communication
thing going on that's that breed of cat
though
siamese are even more like that
yeah
yeah
i mean she definitely does communicate
her wants
uh she's very good at that she's and
it's easy to like determine what it is
that she wants
you know she runs in the room and she's
like bye-bye like she'll talk
like hey
yeah like come on come here i gotta show
you something yeah it's that breed
though and then you gotta follow her and
then she'll like run to whatever it is
beige isn't like that
she's different but she's not dumb
either but that she doesn't have those
same attributes well beijing i think
she's not she's just aloof she doesn't
really give a [ __ ] she's going no she
was a [ __ ] airhead
beijing though every now and then yeah
what's interesting about beijing is that
most of the time she doesn't really give
a [ __ ] she's like whatever whatever you
guys are doing i'm just over here doing
my own thing i'm being beautiful and
being a princess over here
but every now and then she'll get like
really playful like you'll come down the
stairs like to do your laundry or
whatever
and she'll be like hunkered down
underneath like one of these she thinks
she can't see her so i like
i try to pretend that it's like oh my
goodness where's beijing i can't see her
you can't see her but she thinks you
can't
so she's like kind of like hiding under
the stair and then like when you come
down with the laundry she's like
and like she jumps out at you yeah so
she does that every now and then every
now and then she gets very playful but
she's usually usually very aloof
pookie is not aloof
at all
she is up in your [ __ ]
pretty much when she's not sleeping
she's up in your [ __ ] every [ __ ]
second of every day amy says my dream
cat is a maine [ __ ]
i had a friend that had a man [ __ ] it
was a cool cat problem is that their
hair gets really [ __ ] tangled up
if you're not if you don't brush them
you're not staying on top of them
you got to get in there and [ __ ] cut
the damn hair balls out of those cats
man i mean they're they're [ __ ] thick
thick [ __ ] hair
well beijing got to be brushed too she's
a rag doll
um but she has very
i mean which is
uh half persian
yeah so you gotta like brush that [ __ ]
too
uh pookie doesn't have to be brushed
really because she's short hair
but she likes to be brushed yeah
she is super into the brush
she will [ __ ]
she jumps up brush
brush you know there's the whole thing
but um you know it's it's kind of that
too uh
tila says our oldest cat is almost as
big as a maine [ __ ]
mary says uh
they'll tend to if
if dead they'll eat your pancreas
which they might they might
uh let's see
tila says our cats know
when it's time to get up right before
our alarm goes off
well this is why
i mean i wake up early anyway because
basically as soon as the sun comes up
i wake up whether i want to or not
but
pookie very helpfully
will jump up on my chest and be like hey
my treat plate is empty so somebody
needs to get up and attend to the
situation
but you know she does that whole
thing too so she woke me up this morning
about quarter to seven i think it was
i was already kind of half a week
but she jumped up in the bed it's like
er are you getting up or yeah sun's kind
of coming up and it's like i don't
really have any treats so okay do you
guys have any questions or is there any
subjects you guys want to talk about if
not we'll just sit here and talk about
cats over and over again what that's
okay and uh yeah but you know we gotta
we gotta [ __ ] keep the the show
moving you know and having it you know
talk about different situations and
different subjects
it is moving yeah
cheryl says no no jenny pookie must be
brushed ask her ask her yeah
she doesn't even want she doesn't want
me to brush her that's the thing she
wants me to hold the brush
and then she wants to rub her face on it
because i try to like brush her back she
doesn't like shed a lot she does [ __ ] a
little bit she's like short-haired but
i try to do that and she's like oh my
god and she's like no no and she's like
just hold it and then she just like rubs
her face on it
and she will do that for like a [ __ ]
hour cheryl says
the cats must be talked endlessly about
tom right yeah okay
that's what i mean just accept
the way the conversation is going okay
just because i can't talk about cats all
day long though sure you can i just
can't no i can't i'll get bored
i'll get bored really yeah
do you have well water that's easy
yeah that's another good question uh no
we actually don't have water rights here
you gotta pay
to pull water out of this ground
the house has
two different sources of water we've got
to pay them separately one of them is
like uh the city drinking water and the
other one is the water that's used to
water the the lawn
so there's two different waters two
different waters
yeah
tammy says anyone watch peaky blinders
you know what i've been wanting to watch
that forever
our
bartender and friend lee
recommended that show to us
probably like a couple years ago now
oscar says tom yeah i don't tom yeah is
not a question dude
oscar says tom yeah
what kind of [ __ ] is that whatever the
[ __ ] you just said yeah i agree with you
yeah the two different statements
sure
um but yeah but i've been meaning to
watch it and i still haven't
but
many people have recommended it to me so
i will eventually get around to it
you know
uh let's see yeah you know everybody's
talking about cats
you just gotta roll with it tina says
movie trivia
what movie did meryl streep win the
first oscar for meryl streep wait the oh
her first time her first oscars
[ __ ] meryl streep meryl streep god
damn
uh
man i'm too drunk for this yeah meryl
streep i'm trying to think of i feel
like
[Music]
i feel like i'm in jeopardy
come on [ __ ] i don't know i don't know
was it the dingo a baby one wasn't she
wasn't in marathon man was she
was a marathon man was she a marathon
man i thought i thought was wasn't that
meryl streep that was the uh
the girl that [ __ ] uh
dude was [ __ ] sophie's choice selfie
choice i didn't know that okay
so that was based on true story right
because that was kind of like well hey
like remember was it the nazis was the
nazis and they were kind of like hey you
decide which one of your kids to like
kill
because that's i don't remember that
that's how they rolled yeah i don't
remember
tim says 13 o'clock third ten o'clock
podcast is so good thank you very much
looking tammy
uh we're having a good time well that
movie she was in with dustin hoffman
yeah dustin hopping dustin
struggle dustin hopping
well i said man i said that's the hotman
that was [ __ ] marathon man rebecca
says kramer versus kramer
oh [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i
remember that one wasn't ricky wasn't
ricky schroeder in that when he was like
a little bitty kid am i totally high
right now
was he the kid in that
somebody help me help me yeah you're not
gonna help me somebody help me no i
don't know
it was crammer versus grammar i don't
remember that i remember that movie but
i remember it being very
i was a little kid when it came out
what's the word i'm looking for
it's very maudlin yeah
um
but i don't know i haven't seen it for a
long time so i can't really i don't
really want to like say too much about
it but i kind of feel like it was too
much like it's like misery porn
yeah you know
but i might feel differently about it if
i saw it now that's kind of how i
thought about it then
when i saw it
but i was pretty young i was like a
teenager when i saw it
okay oh okay i was right yeah
i was gonna say i thought that was ricky
shredder right yeah
he was in [ __ ] silver spoons in the
80s
you guys remember that [ __ ]
ricky schroeder
silver spoons
yeah you grew up in the 80s too right no
i remember that
they're asking if i'm doing solar panels
now i'm about to do solar panels solar
panels solar panels
do you guys see a birdemic
solar panels
solar panels please see bernard we'll
watch the rifftrax version don't watch
it without riptracks because
it's unwatchable but
they're actually rip tracks live yeah we
went and saw rifftrax live burdemic that
was one of the funniest [ __ ] things
i've ever seen
yeah so watch that i think it's on 2b
maybe
but yeah
best bill paxton roll film
ooh
i'm gonna say either aliens or frailty
frailty was his best role
he directed that [ __ ] too
i mean i kind of feel like i want to
give some like love to frailty because i
kind of feel like
his best movie was aliens
that's what i just said but the best
role that he did was frailty
yeah that's such a good movie god damn
it and like i said he directed it too
and it's like
i feel like not enough people talk about
frailty
it's so good it's so good
i mean
uh cheryl says near dark for me oh
that's also a good choice near dark is
awesome
uh
strawdogs78 says watch yellowjackets so
many people have like recommended
yellowjackets i will watch it i promise
it's like lord of the flies makes the
shining meets heathers
which
that's already making it feel like
[ __ ] awesome
oh red
it went red for a second but okay
we've been doing it we've actually had a
good yes that was the first time that it
went red like all night yeah so okay
uh frailty was good the ending simple
plan oh that's also a good one i've been
actually meaning to read that novel
because so many people have told me
it's uh it's the same guy that wrote the
ruins which i did a review of the movie
like and i think i did the book too
actually because i did read the book
would you rather be a part of a vampire
or a werewolf pack
red be vampires because as far as i know
vampires were immortal and i don't think
werewolves were
see okay i don't think werewolves were
immortal
i'm kind of torn because vampires i
would like to be immortal
uh but the nice well i don't know i
guess vampires would be better i was
gonna say werewolves if you weren't
immortal werewolves would be better
because it wasn't
permanent like it would only be like the
full moon and you turn into a wolf and
kill people and the rest of time you'd
be normal
which that'd be cool too
but
the whole immortality situation yeah i'm
gonna go with vampires let me go with
vampires because they kind of have all
the powers of
werewolves
but they live forever
and theoretically
they could
um
you know
be like super rich you'd like invest
some [ __ ] and then like 200 years from
now you'd have like [ __ ] up the money
and you could live like [ __ ]
and rice vampires that would be cool
uh werewolves have more fun so cheryl
werewolves seem to have less control
that's one thing too it's like i kind of
feel like you don't
you'd be normal most of the time and
then like oh once a month you turn into
an animal so i don't know that's
what was blacula's true name mama walden
i'm a waldie yeah
honestly you know what and i remembered
that so quickly because
uh a book that i just read
a novel that i just read that i'm
it's not going up
when is it going up it's going up the
14th the book that i just read book
review uh a book the book was called
dark corner and it was essentially like
salem's lot
meets blacula yeah
so
uh so was that i didn't love the book it
was it was okay it was pretty good
but
in that book the author of it who i
think was brandon massey
he
obviously was homaging
blacula because one of the characters
was named mama waldy yeah he wasn't one
of the vampires he was actually one of
the vampires like helpers
like his half human servant type
situation and he was called mamawali and
i was like i see what you did there i
see that but yeah that was his name mama
walty
uh yeah tv asked that question yeah
yeah i i already we already talked about
it before team uh [ __ ]
blacula and screen black of the screen
were the two main
stories that that [ __ ] anne rice used
to help her write the vampire chronicles
because it
those stories actually said well wait a
minute what's this like from the
vampire's point of view you know and
that's where that's where the vampire
chronicles came from
before that time the vampire was just a
just a monster
they didn't really give that
that [ __ ]
that character the [ __ ] the credit it
was due
i don't really understand it
it had to do with the thinking of the
time when you
looked at bella lugosi's [ __ ] old
vampire movie
why
dracula wasn't the [ __ ] main
character and why you weren't seeing
his point of view and it's the way it
should have been
but for some reason they wanted to put
it
more towards van helsing and the [ __ ]
mortals
you know which that didn't really make
much sense even back in those days you
know
well the thing about a lot of horror and
i think i got into this because um today
i recorded a review of the shape of
water
which is guillermo del toro's
answer to
creature from the black lagoon where
he's kind of like what if the creature
was actually like an intelligent
creature and that fell in love with a
human woman it was like consensual
um
so
i kind of like
this whole take of like let's see
like if we humanize the monster
and the weird thing like you mentioned i
kind of feel like this is not something
that really occurred
to
bit well i don't know i don't know if i
want to say that because um
there have been some monster movies like
i said frankenstein uh king kong [ __ ]
like that that we're sympathetic toward
the monster
but i kind of feel like the overarching
[Music]
you know thing
in movies at that time was like you know
we're the humans they're the monster it
has to be defeated
and
to me it's a lot more interesting
whether the villain is a monster or not
whether the villain is a human or
whatever the [ __ ] i think it's like way
more interesting to like explore
what the villain's motivation is because
the most interesting villains to me are
villains that have their own
agenda because every villain
thinks they're the hero of their own
story
and i kind of feel like if you're
a writer if you're a movie maker
it would behoove you to kind of like
approach things from that standpoint
because that makes your villains a lot
more interesting
villains are a lot more interesting when
they have their own motivations they
think they're the good guy in their own
story
um everybody else sees them as a bad guy
obviously but they don't see themselves
that way
and that makes for like some really
interesting
[ __ ] to happen
so
i don't yeah i don't really know why
they didn't really
it really seemed to like not occur to
them like back in the old days
maybe like not to any great extent i
guess
but
you know
i'm right out with cheese uh tila said i
never saw a shape of water is it good um
okay so i recorded a review i
loved it
but
it's gonna depend on the person it's not
a horror movie it's um
it's a fantasy
love story kind of i kind of feel like
the love story is
uh
important in it but it's mostly like
this is weird to say but it's mostly
like a fantasy but it's mostly like a
heist movie because
a lot of it is kind of
tied up with her like trying to get him
out of the facility or whatever
um
and i think a lot of people had made a
big deal about oh my god she has sex
with a fish man
um which you know that does happen in
the movie but
in the movie it's it's not as weird as
you're thinking it is you know what i
mean like if you just like read it
you're like oh my god that's [ __ ] up i
don't watch that but jeez asking what
was quince movie in the [ __ ] orca or
what was quits boot boat in the movie
jaws what was the name of it it sounds
familiar [ __ ]
was it called the orca i thought it was
called i think it might have been called
the orca wouldn't it i thought it was
called the orca i think it might have
been called i'm not sure been a long
time you guys it's almost seven o'clock
that's okay
you know what it's friday it is
you wanna go to mankins
i don't know
do i i don't have any money so i got
money
i got money
i wouldn't mind going
i mean if you want i'll drive
i'm ready to go
we don't stay all night
well i'm not ready to go i need like an
hour or two to get ready well it's seven
now i know
yeah
are we really gonna do this and i'm
tired
i'll do
if you get tired then we'll just come
back
i'm already tired
but you have to go i'll go
okay yeah see she don't want it she
wanted to go with brazil no you can't
okay no he has [ __ ] you don't give a
[ __ ] if i go by myself nope yeah see i
don't believe that if i go by myself
she'll be like what are you doing all
night that [ __ ] will show up on my on
my motorcycle what are you doing why
aren't you back already no i wouldn't
okay all right
i think you want to go do you want to go
i guess
it's friday
okay
we got to keep [ __ ] rolling you know
what i'm talking about okay
all right john gore says i got to
re-watch the grifters which i actually
really need to re-watch at some point i
was just thinking of john cusack i
watched that 1408 movie review yeah i
mean honestly i want to rewatch the
grifters too angelica houston is in that
and i love her
so
uh you know so i want to see sure tell
me stay home and drink no i'm gonna stay
on my drink
and tina's going yeah spend tom's money
it doesn't cost us that much to go there
i mean like i said i've already drank so
much at home and it's like when i get
there i don't really want to drink
anymore you don't drink that much
honestly by the time i get there i'm
just kind of like just play some good
[ __ ] so i can dance i think i'll just
drink water i think the last time we
went between me and jenny was only 25
bucks because i had one drink i had one
drink yeah that i could that i didn't
finish yeah and then the rest of the
night i said i told anna i was just like
just just give me water so she just kept
like refilling the water yeah so we were
there for like hours and hours and i
just drank like gallons of gallons of
water i had one drink
and i didn't finish it yeah it was it
was a whiskey and coke you're saying you
all have good y'all have fun
yeah
how long have we been on
uh
two hours and 20 okay yeah it's been a
good show it's been a good job all right
all right well it was good to have it's
good to see you guys
we're gonna go get ready and we're gonna
go out
and we will see you guys when monday
sunday sunday we'll see you we'll see
you sunday yeah we'll do a matinee we'll
talk about i don't even know what movie
we'll talk about we'll watch a movie
tomorrow and then we'll figure something
out yeah tom's rushing me out the door i
gotta go man i'm it's in my mind i'm
gonna go
[Laughter]
people want some food so feed poop
seriously okay
all right so
i guess
just me and spock
me and spock here by ourselves
all right thanks everybody for dropping
by thanks for super chats this evening
we will see you guys on sunday gonna
talk about some movie we don't know what
it is yet because we haven't watched it
but
all right so i guess we're gonna go out
tonight we'll see how that goes uh so
okay
have a good weekend you guys we will see
you guys on sunday afternoon
bye